ok ok tout le monde ben laden en est
reparti quoi ouais mais les vrais
stakhanoviste après un permis mais les
ailes les un clasico oui donc enseigné à
commenter les oublie ce qui va commencer
très bientôt
à vrai dire qu'ils viennent je connais
pas vraiment bien eu ni l'un ni l'autre
max jadot un peu en fait très lo lo
américain je connais pas du tout
l'américaine aux souvenirs le web ok je
sais qu'il a un classement des 100 je
sais que parfois il prend le scalp des
fours joueurs mais à part cela en fait
je connais pas grand chose sur eux
surfent aussi au quai auquel joue pas
mal d ouverture aussi se défendre
et tu crois que moi je vais faire une
histoire sinon si c'était pour dire
qu'ils jouent qu'à se dire en tant que
favori je pense que plutôt mars au bout
comme pagesjaunes avaient largement
parce que t'as pas vu le match sera
commenté avec mathieu non c'est un
cinéma
oui j'ai regardé le prime d'heures 2019
donc le parasite tête avec ma femme
d'ailleurs c'est marrant je sais qu'ils
ont en fait le film s'appelle les
parasites mais en français s'appelle
l'opposé pourquoi parce qu'il y avait il
ya longtemps un film français les
parasites
excusez moi parce que j'ai lu beaucoup
après le film sur ce film et donc je me
suis demandé pourquoi telle différence
entre un titre ou de titeuf le film est
bon pas parmi les meilleurs mais mes
meilleurs mais le veut le film je vous
le conseille je pense que les médias le
cinéma coréen arrête toi on a évidemment
les cours ayant son permis l'émir la
révolution ouais ce film qu'est ce que
j'adore de regarder les expressions
faciales de mon cerveau c'est un vrai
régal
je pense que peut-être celle où tu me
fais peur à chaque fois mairiga fait des
petits pouces d'état
en fait je pense que l'école est bien
mélangé tu vois moi je crois qu'il ya
une gradation dans la méchanceté blad
certains nakamura blond mais déjà un peu
méchant tu sens mais là en fait quand tu
commences à croiser nakamura avec de
l'iranien là si tu veux tu te la
suivante nc c'est un peu comme les
chiens c'est tata les pitbulls tu as des
trucs là prête à acheter encore plus
méchant cci se mélangent dans dobermann
un pitbull c'est un peu ça malgré toi
ils ont pris naka et ils ont mélangé de
l'iranien pour créer un truc encore plus
méchant tu vois la ciotat en termes de
violence alors que l'autre à côté qui
ont de la pression c'est jean legros
berger allemand a chihuahua avec eux
dans la merde ce qui va me faire bouffer
par le club
ouais cgt une gradation des gens cessent
donc on prévoit un grand avantage pour
moscou en fait ça peut être marrant
parce que ma doudou - brown arrivé
d'aller boulez willibald en fait ils
vont juste d'élire l'iran va défoncer
les états unis ou en national une vision
politique parce que firent moudja déjà
défoncée sevian est donc là le deuxième
petit americanos donc les fumades the
interlace de la guerre peut-être vrai
hein enfin dans sa tombe un corps est
beaucoup plus des bulles aux spectateurs
du coup on est pour les iraniens à fond
bah j'aime toujours les commandes parce
que ton et antoine est bon quand les
trois des cinq je crois bien sûr
d'abord il va essayer ça con il faut
toujours sinon bon sûr je dois je suis à
100% sûr que les mecs on va faire je
suis leur fusion à ce que j'ai au gros
sel de cheval et les révisions qui dit
que le match dépend de comment max ou à
manger à leurs enfants
avant d'essayer d'abord qualifié ce qui
collait de cette montagne le fond tout
de suite sa carrière si je vois pas
pourquoi faire pour être original c'est
pas son truc
et si je faire cavalier un set rock f5
et caraïbes six mois pour le faire mais
ce qu'on peut le faire
six premières frappes mais je pense que
poweo pourrait rejoindre à sauf que ok
il est vrai petit rond comme cinq
locataires de f4 coller ce cadre est
moins bon kouadio je pense pas qu'il va
falloir jouer à 5 alors comme la
dernière fable il ya eu un petit truc en
aura parfois je dois dire que
malheureusement la dernière fois alors
je l'on va essayer de les bouger un peu
mais à la fois pour le speech est comme
il avait déjà eu la partie l'après-midi
de la nouvelle les gens se sont est un
con c'est à dire que le chat était juste
mort il y avait du monde
ça toujours retenu 506 en première page
je souligne mais les gens pouvaient même
plus écrire tu sais la fatigue quoi est
ce un peu le même si la rue quentin se
passe et ce que la louga il écrit salut
les amis mais il n'était pas là cet
aprem donc il est tout frais mais les
eaux tu sais c'est comme le tour de
france quoi ils ont fait une première
vente à une deuxième montagne ils
peuvent plus écoutées comme les ondes
friands de jeux à 4 et puis quand je
prévois une grosse victoire pour maxauto
ceux qui peuvent jouer à 4 ici et je
pense qu'ils vont pas tenir longtemps
parce que j'ai pas de nom pour ce coup
d'essai contre les noirs jouent à cinq
pour revoir bruch et when he poos 05
prodi à nos canaux
ok fait donc tu veux dire que mon idée
de f5 et émile bas tout est mieux que
jeu à 5 puis à 4 blocs à terme et et les
gramatois 2500 ha mais par contre j'ai
pas commenter avec la copine de jay
frictions mais j'ai plus dès lors que
lui sur tchekhov ou pas non jean lemoine
on a un peu mon nom maintenant cinq
garçons sans réfléchir au bois france 5
qu'il comprend sur ce sens que des
cadres et déjà 2,5 football est beau
mais je n'ai pas chiante itunes dès à
jeter quand il ya un an monte en niveau
depuis je serai ce qui fait en fait
quelqu'un ment 21 qui dit le mec à
gauche donc mcdoom a pas l'air trop
juniors ça va c'est comme en 1996 je
joue un tournoi en indonésie et en a
souvent dit mais avec je la ressens les
1 kg auteurs jouent les enfants sont
absents web os est l un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde et dépendront pour les
français autres absents - et
on a parlé de tout et rien n'est
abandonné il m'a raconté qu'un 19 76 il
a joué le tour le championnat du monde
junior à burgos 6000 combien 6-2 en
dessous de 16 ans ouais donc et avec as
part of you may qui avait 13 ans
le mari après oui il va discours vous
fait croire que le marché actuel du mec
de 18 ans il était énorme déjà et il est
au poil ou et tout le reste
donc ce n'est qu'une anecdote mais bon
ça veut dire que donc on a de bons
pronostics pour les carrières de
morceaux de rue je fais ya un petit truc
maranda une petite anecdote
ouais à un moment donné fabien je vous
entends à gibraltar et eux c'est qu'elle
est à genieau 21 ouais ils jouent tour à
gibraltar il ya le petit du cash qui est
très fort go qu'elle joue cash et fabien
commence à m'expliquer que mais il n'a
pas 13 en quoi il m'a dit mais il est
peintre il a pas 13 ans ou 12 ans ils
ont entamé des contacts il dit là-bas 12
ans il n'a pas 13 ans il a plus ça se
voit il me dit c'est juste ça se voit et
puis oui bon ok mais peut-être il est
juste un peu grand pour son âge ou quoi
est familier mais ces masses ou qu'il
vous dit quoi
juste ça donne quoi 10 ans a tourné
qu'en fait c'est juste même pas une
rumeur
six visites en sondant le tournoi amazon
qui est un peu grand fable dit me répète
est juste on était très heureux de se
dire toi tu dis sur la chaîne
et puis en fait tout d'un coup tout le
monde dit qu'il est grand et en fait ça
bien que de maso qui passe devant sa
table à 10,6 pour 13 décès c'est
extraordinaire quoi voilà allez dire un
truc tu t'es tu allais me couper non
mais ce que je veux dire parce qu'ils
ont ils arrivent dans plusieurs pays de
changer le bateau naissance de ska
studios universal c'est une pratique
très ancienne très ancienne c'est existe
toujours et on veut rien dire mais des
probabilités un peu pâle
bon ben c'est la politique vous cache
pas il ya tellement dernier à haut
niveau ce serait étonnant
enfin bon là maintenant on voit aller
les conséquences de la crise et du crime
et du grillon il a invité les branches
de khat et les ovaires avec ce 5 est
maintenant un jour au lieu de le voir
perdre soi cowboy imbéciles ce soit bien
sûr de sept champions 10 1 ouais donc
c'est bien sûr c'est bien ridicule 8e et
9e coup pas d'autres mots vous me
critiquer de terre critiquant toujours
mais il n'y a pas de mon bien sûr pour
ça mais ses critiques à de critiquer
quelqu'un de critiques en justice était
de 117 m en face complètement je sais
très critique envers ceux qui me
critiquent parce que ces critiques ont
critiqué ces gens là il faut plutôt par
contre ça aussi il faut attendre ce jour
la seule où on glisse ou pas quoi bien
bienvenue à calais mais quand tu sais
après la partie de griffoul cet après
midi est-ce que cela se joue en partie
le nom est mêlé à un moment donné ça
déconne aime quand même le niveau est
élevé quand même vers la fin tu as vu ou
3 à 3,5 ce 4 ces trois à un moment donné
bon quand même
quand même le calcul est quand même
pas mal de couleurs mais sauf que ici
c'est une parade des fautes bien sûr et
je sais pas je pense que peut-être ai-je
l'air ces gosses ils ont trop l'habitude
de jouer les poules est je pense que les
voleurs c'est pas bien pour le niveau
général est ce que dit gary aussi ils
interdisent pas des noms mais je sais
pas ce qu'il faut pour tous et les
premières réactions
de quelqu'un pas trop fort mais je sais
pas mais normalement comment ça que tu
fermes ta propre pourquoi est elle
finalement tu le mets sur ces temps où
le sceptre mariant ok mais pas bien sûr
ça tourne autour de l'égalité peut-être
les noirs sont il y aura encore mais sow
france avant chaque moyen qui arrive on
sent que sa couleur qu'elle voulait
apprendre qu'il prend à deux médias ça
en avril sa femme enfant
la chaire spectateurs si vous voulez
encore progresser aux échecs ne jouais
pas trop de boulettes s'il vous plaît
donc vous pouvez jouer des bulles les
boulettes
ce sont les blessures aux jambes au
bruit si vous voulez pas de cette fête
pas s'il vous plaît parce que c'est
criminel
les bulls les bullet sont des boulets
ben justement sur les gens bon je
suppose qu'ils ont maintenant c'est déjà
les barques sont mieux prédits 6 passes
4 pièces anr bon con comme max au dos à
la tendance donnait pas bien joué
pendant deux coups et l'auteur faire
découvrir une série mais après de ce
qu'on a vu avec mathieu donc ses comptes
et au cinéma
à dix on va faire des français on
regarde comme les cinq pour les poteaux
d'un g4 première partie est terminée
double attaque ce joli donc je montre
donc tout donc sûrs de partir pour port
et ce non pas du tout moi j'ai utilisé
blitz progressait même pas de boulette
comme un rugbyman ans affirme déjà
pareil c'est comment il s'entraîne avec
l'hyper bull est est ce que tu sais ce
que cette non tu joues avec 30 secondes
il fait même le superbus va comment
s'appelait avec 15 secondes et partie
non666 joue à ça que tu pense qu'il peut
être futur champion du monde
une fois du mal a dit non je pense
pareil que toi mais elle peut oublier
c'est incroyable quand même d'être aussi
bien aux échecs à ce cours est aussi
content de ma vie mais parfois la vie
rude bon c'est bien sûr finir webcet
d'invocateur afin durdos commenté me
salue ici que même barque
moi quand je jouais en bullet la partie
ne dure pas deux minutes dit buzz quoi
sabine kinch est allé à l'ofce salua
pichari je remarque qu'il ya un an
battant je voulais remettre un lien vers
la soirée de samedi
ouais mais c'est pas c'est comme visé le
problème c'est que c'est pas c'est pas
ma chaîne à oui je fais parce que je
[Musique]
journal chilien la lbu que la partie en
train de se fier façon c'est un live
détente un blabla ce soir faut pas être
trop stressé sur l'analyse de la partie
trop de trop de live tu le live après
surtout vu le niveau quoi mais c'est pas
que fil rouge a joué un hyper bullet je
ne suis plus haut en fait tous ma par
contre à un moment donné je voudrais
bien de regarder comme on joue pas ce
que tu aimes des comédiens tout le monde
parle autant de fear is able en fait
tout le monde parle autant de fair use
maintenant qu'ils ont parlé de vrilly et
quelques années ils sont arrêtés mais
pas tout le monde a compris que c'est
pas ça et donc maintenant fear is a
peut-être enfin qu'ils gagnent
finalement et après avoir signé le sous
le règne de carson encore pendant un
quart de siècle a peut-être rien on y
perd bullet mais qui ont un univers bull
est ok mais pas si trois quatre et c5
c'est le meilleur et c'est moi qui
apportait beaucoup à cette ligne là moi
les gens à part de nos savoirs pas joué
en grèce connaissent pas les théories
non plus il cumule
oui c'est une mauvaise version 2 c'est
une très mauvaise version d'os magazine
pour les noirs parce que les bras ne
sont pas forcés maintenant d'échanger
les pièces des moteurs à zurich qui
parle du match sa caméra il bloque un
peu de temps en temps mais sinon alors
qu'un point ce qu'il faut ça pour le
public où il faut sado les îles
[Musique]
je propose d'organiser un match mal ou
sous contre navarra les deux tout fou
mais il est marrant il est fou fou
marrant non
we hope faut pas méchant n'en fout
gentil ouais vous adorable même un peu
grosse et son gabarit c'est faux c'est
six fours non en fait c'est un pitbull
croisé avec un chihuahua ouais ouais
voilà enfin des chihuahuas sec sa gueule
quand même beaucoup mais il est lui
aussi en fait ouais mais gentiment tu
vois ça fait quand même de la peine pour
la maman explique vous le caniche
volcaniques ça a donné quoi elle voulait
le gris chaud comme ça fait nous demande
tout cas les bois donc ça continue
bomber et mass là maintenant à la bien
sûr une mauvaise version 2 du kabyle aux
hommes orthodoxes
ça veut dire l'aviso d'un passif que les
dessins baissier s'est pas trop bien
mais c'est pas si facile de réflecteurs
ça
par exemple si les barbus au qatar
maintenant il ya toujours que le cadre
et les bandes en autant de monde fawcett
cholestérol c'est ça l'un des pièges
très raffiné faut dire que les deux
villes
donc il faut savoir de télé donc
d'aboutir de les bourgeons ce soit d'un
modèle soit 407 des gens parlent pas à
cause de cavalli de cinq mois je préfère
céder je pense qu'aujourd'hui je vais
très tranchant comment ça marche
le plus jeune plus que je dirais je vois
ce que pouvaient se voir jouer car en
dessous portables n'attend que ça je
veux montrer essuie-tout votre arrogance
jamais vu avant rija si j'ai regardé
l'analyse de la partie de mv lille a
fait 99 % de précisions ça sent longines
dessous ouais ok l'exemple achi typiques
comme les noirs on mérite d'aller
ouverture archi typique bien sûr les
bons ont un bon avantage ce que le ou
fait pas ou ce temps donc c'est un rêve
en fait qu'ils ont pu obtenir un peut
pas obtenir n'importe quelle culture
peut pas tout voir ici je sais ça me
rappelait faux bon nombre de
catastrophes
c'est qu'attaquant tu tiens ça me
rappelle
mais bien sûr tour ces trois avec les
cinq de ses possibles 5
d'accord ça mais bien sûr tout ça me
fout brens paillis appartient pas ici
parce que oui cool
houphouët 5 si tu veux je suis dit si tu
es déçu
foubert maintenant après 4 a toujours
foi ci soit très bon bon mais ça va
encore peut-être hockey wire c'est billy
et ceux qui viennent il ya trois ans je
suppose c'est quoi ce ne dessèche de 6 h
4 rue ça s'inscrive je pense bon c'est
fini
donc
mais ça va encore pour les blancs oh ça
va mais pour football à l'école
soviétique dont on comme ça bah oui et
non comment je ne faut plus quoi donc du
coup il danse quand même de partout avec
le québec
non mais je pense qu'ils se parle à lui
tout seul en fait ça m'inquiète 26 quand
tu quand tu me reste les échecs facteurs
par vous oui moi je croyais moi j'ai toi
et si c'était si c'était à demi finales
des tournois classiques eux seraient
était juste injouable contournent ces
trois jeunes diplômés pour le pays qui
ont été ordinaires oui oui pour les
publics et sonia porot l'adversaire au
1er juin
ok mais ça aurait été une force au
contraire il fait fort tant mieux pour
nous rires mais pas pour l'heure vous
avez enfin abouti mais j'attends mieux
quelque part sans arrêter son arme
secrète quoi il le poids de mille fois
bien qu'à osaka - non il ya un accord
assez bien comprises que dire oui à
[Rires]
l'europe sa caméra coup tellement
maurane les achètent pour hull ouais bah
oui c'est un festival quoi tient ce
créatif de twitter la dame sur l'a54 qui
avait régné dommage ce mec ou à millas
gevers il a gagné des partages le mesle
a gagné de match comme moi je les badges
avec la grande claque robe où je
m'attends pas du tout je pense qu'ils
ont avec à quatre premiers
klaus favoris ou des bronches associé à
la com c'est pire qu'avec un faux cul de
bresson sextoys à prendre un froid rade
bon bien sûr on comprend que une fois du
camion je suis ok c'est ce doit être mal
pour les blancs les questions s'agit de
prouver ou pas mais bien sûr c'est un
très mauvais augure donc tous les tours
de quatre normalement marche pas à cause
des raisons claires j'ai pas quelque
chose quand on sert d'un burn 2-2
highway et même si fou et 7
peu importe toujours non non non je
préfère d'abord un tour c'est bien oui
d'amour oui donc sinon c'est
catastrophique
la colère saxe le problème auquel est à
l'inde pour le site 163 l'autre problème
commerçants qui arrive donc faut trouver
un cours à profond quand les cinq
domicile donc
et qu'est-ce que les préparer sur bourse
de paris grand chose du toit
s'il faut pas trop à tous et 3,6 faut
boire peu importe j'ai pas tout ce
travail peut pas prendre sur des quatre
portes tout ça moi je veux colère sont
donc qu'est ce qui est sûr c'est jouable
mais ça risque d'être le score risque de
techcrunch très grand je pense mais
c'était ma prédiction d'avant match
peut-être il va gagner le match avant
commencer les boulettes
ouais mais pas mathématiquement parce
qu'il faudrait gagner de 30 points c'est
impossible mais il peut avoir plus est
plus 8 et du coup c'est quasiment fini
bah ce que je vois et pour moi c'est sûr
qu'il faut faire
ok donc quelques longs jeux parfaits
depuis longtemps donc quelqu'un comme
amputer les bords ici
d'amore torcéen il va prendre six
paquets sur dance 2 il veut jouer dans
ma tête je suppose forceps je suis sûr
que sa pire donc damas est elle est là
on joue tous à rajouter des mots forts
vois je crois que relief 5 et caves
roche 4g 5 avoir 5 damas trois mois n'a
fait tour à 30 ans il a créé laférois
j'ai certainement mais c'est une belle
verrière qui viennent d'ailleurs
remerciez pas c'est dommage mais c'est
ce parce que c'était bon ok oui il veut
jouer sans quelques calculs et ce en
quelques leçons sur ce faux quand les
2,5 était beaucoup plus fort marie je
pense qu'au large et des ventes avec les
dessins que c'est un pied cinq échecs
dans le premier simple mais il faut qu
elle ait perdu tout son avantage
ouais mais perdu tout son avantage il
était tellement bien en argos
c'est terrifiant non
qu'on s'est connus les finales il faut
jouer sans le roi du vaste parc et b5 et
c5 r non parce que le top repas
mais l'offrît la haye prem de connexion
pour par am hommes ne pouvaient pas
faire quelques visites au coude avant
pour un hétéro carioca 3 45.24 de
cissokho
c'est dommage qu'ils aient pas commencer
par cas mais il part à 1000m pas calculé
qu'un homme il joue plutôt au feeling en
fait parce que changer les termes et
faire ce qu'il a fait mais tout le monde
allait chercher chez moi
camaret avec eux dans des structures de
diaw et ses 3 2 les me plaît il à perdre
il va tomber par mois n'est pas de
connexion ouais tu n'as pas de connexion
super g3 wave non mais là pas de
connexion internet
judas annonce que par ama perdre le
match
tu peux pas je veux sans connexion il va
payer ça un jour ou l'autre
beaumont toute interview à 8 fruits
achetés sont cinq jets d'affaires nous
ça va être chaud ouais ça fait nul mais
si tu sais que le speech est financée
déjà joué à la connexion oui on m'a
raconté que laissait mal de nier
l'encontre de nadine on est ce qu'il
doit faire au cad à dommage non mais
c'est un peu le point faible de cette
compétition trois iphone c'est un peu le
point faible de la compétition bat ya
trop de matches qui joue sur la
connexion et katia n'était pas trop déçu
de sa défaite contre danielian au
premier tour non aux patrons aux qu'elle
était surprise mais pas trop parce qu
hélas corps et nos contrées le marais
donc elle était très surprise mais pas
trop parce que je pense déjà qu'ils
auraient leur très très peu d'expérience
bonjour la médina qui a très très bien
joué pour cette compétition
surtout le deuxième acte contre coup
c'était contre ou non c'est pas contre
eux aussi non c'était contre la joueuse
indienne harricana vraiment bien joué en
fait j'ai toujours bien aimé comment des
liens à jour pas beaucoup de
connaissances énormément d'optimiser et
très énergétiques non cette position bon
ça se joue pas comme ça avec le noir
depuis 2000 après avoir bu 5 à vue soit
férié mais c'est une grosse réussite
pour les bombes l'habitude de commander
il faut rencontrer ça si on veut
égaliser
excusez moi mais j'ai vraiment eu disons
que quand je passe à côté de chez moi et
les papilles joue sur une table en bois
d'habitude je passe sans commentaire
je passe juste je commente pas hélène
germa nouvelle catégorie parce que ça
bloque le fou mais oui mais et s'il est
noir violet griser quand tu fais p4 cb
après les noirs jouent près 5 avec les
deux à cinq au prochain bien sûr il
traîne et noir laisse pas jouer présente
parce que après foix iii est doué mais
c'est le fils doit parfois que tu vois
je mens obtenir dans ta vie en ce moment
mais toujours eu quatre pour justement à
broc et on fout mais excusez moi mais
aujourd'hui je vais des traîtres à ce
que c'est je sais pas anglaise fois les
grammys
ils sont quand même assez fort
classiquement glissement mais ça vient
d'où tu penses c'est parce qu'ils n'ont
pas assez de cultures ce qui calcule
trop je sais pas moi je vois moins pas
2a d'adhésion à la logique générale à
part de la culture de la couture même
pas de logique générale
disons alors dr relate comment soigner
ça prend de l'oubli au sérieux regarde
dôme et la can coupe du monde rapide
je me suis fait éliminer par kaspar au
juste et donc à lui reprocher son
prochain match ils jouent contre des shu
ce n'est pas encore pour gérer soi on
appelle de la part du manager de
kasparov est ce que tu peux venir
hilton pour faire quelques parties
d'entraînement
bien sûr je viens un jour qui au cratère
par tient chaque partie il joue très
très très sérieuse n'a pas de bla bla
bla pas de quoi que ce soit pas en rire
je voulais continuer bien sûr il est
d'innocence quand il a vu qu il peut
continuer en comptant sur montante mais
c'est risqué non il fait nul je vous
dirai ce que je veux dire mais
l'approché tout à fait différent hélas
jusqu'où baffe les cases les diagana les
lieux où les livres font et les pères de
fou au pape
ils s'en foutent réellement ils bougent
les pièces mais il joue vite on se
croire dans un emploi bavay troll quoi à
vitrolles quelques pas sur la table a
dit bière au ve la balle est donc
hauteur 5 allée à sancho est déjà bien
combien de votre cas déjà allés et
relève
c'est ce niveau là mais c'est bien ça le
hockey est roi djoudj pas une une autre
contre 5 contre tout le monde et gagnent
parfois maubert
donc
ok les besoins sont bien en cours et
leur avantage en grande partie mais ça
reste un peu mieux et loire doivent être
précis bien sûr donc il faut quand même
essayer de faire notre course sur ces 5
donc je sais pas peut-être quelque chose
comme cavale et ses huit fouet trois
fois 6 me ou maintenant que les fouilles
peut-être s il veut jouer quel est celui
de voir si c'était une bonne idée contre
l'a45 donc justement non mais là c'est
bien ce qui fait non là je peux t'y pas
peut-être c'est même mieux que ce que je
dis c'est bien possible des six mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est quoi
l'avenir du fou man ils voient qu'ils
violent que 7,7
ils voient pas que il va perdre la
partie oui la partie à cause du fait
qu'ils voient que se propose d il va pas
les aider d'autres mais c'est comme ça
que ça jour dans les cafés mais je veux
un coup il pense après qu'on ait les
fous pas mal non mais bien ici c'est
spécial quand même à l ail j'aime plus
ou la wii elle bouge pas trop les têtes
oui oui un peu quand même mais moi ouais
l'est les îles guenon mais regarde il
s'est complètement vie c'est maintenant
pas rêver si c'était quand même spécial
non c'est très très optimiste
geffray qui ont bien
jeffrey bayard revient forcément enfin
jean-luc j'ai vu que j'avais fait quand
même des cadeaux la tour d un ukase 4
c'est pas mal 400 qui bloque le foot
c'est noël g13 qui fêtent noël on dit on
mais dommage qu'il n'a pas une autre
compétition avant ça fait deuxième match
que je commente rapide
comment s'appelle type i just speechless
juniors ça me donne de plus en plus
envie 2e ligne australien qui tarde à
venir
we made you les goizé quelques par
semaine parce que le le niveau du truc
adulte est quand même bien fusé bien
plus évoluée bonne foi des fois pas
faute et voiliers se fait éliminer
paquet nouri joue contre firoud à c'est
peut-être alors une perte nettement plus
forte que notre salaire ça bah oui oui
bien sûr dont le vainqueur va sortir de
l'autoroute rcd est que plus savoureux
semble tout seul mouvement sportif du
psg 4 4 savourez semble bien gunino
stade de buenos aires s'appelle amin'ny
on l'appelle gunino quand vanina c'est
une petite blague j'ai su qu'elle te
ferait rire je connais ton humour
malheureusement les recevoir parce que
ça influence
de toute évidence que je connais des
femmes voient pas souvent un peu en tête
de sang ils sont fous quoi
je vous parle a dit à la blague ça l'a
eu
[Rires]
j'ai su que ça les fait rire voir un
jour par contre l'histoire du de l'ours
quoi oui oui c'est une des meilleures
blagues non mais lourde balle
exceptionnelle avec de l'ours
ce n'est peut-être pas le meilleur non
bon ça tourne toujours autour d'auch +3
plus 5006 plus est
tu sais quoi je sais que c'est un truc
quand j'atteins les 30000 dates noms
déjà lundi soir pour la soirée à cannes
on raconte la blague de l'ours
pour ceux qui viennent donc pour ceux
qui viennent à cannes pour la soirée il
y aura la blague de l'ours mais c'est
toi qui vois le faire parce qu'ils te
tue le fait mieux que moi je la fais
bien que le fémina tu l'as fait bien un
tour ici je pense que je le pense je
sais que c'est pas quelqu'un moi fois ci
le buzz
non mais je vais très bien et du coup
et du coup après pour les trente mille
abonnés peut-être quand on fera un live
on refera la blague pour le lynx nés
dans les 30 minutes pour que tout
dossier théâtre un ouais là et c'est
peut-être notre meilleur live de loin
mais regardez les fouettés noir la audi
enfants qui y sévit tout bon ok vous nos
excuses et que cette dernière couleur ne
commande pas d'accord il ya quelque
chose à côté
si l'on regarde les bouffées mieux en
france ou en russie
pour écoutez je ne suis pas un grand
amateur de la cuisine russe de la
cuisine française non plus désolé mais
puisque tout entendre les beaux voyages
adore ce nombre les cuisines asiatiques
ouzbeks
donc j'aime bien avant à trois rues si
je me débrouille très bien donc je ne
peux pas prendre mais en france paraît
donc
[Musique]
ouais ça c'est prendre les dernières
voix j'ai vu de telles choses c'était
qu'ils prendraient c'était 19 81 3 ou 19
84 des gens qui jouaient ça comme les
gens aiment jouer vers le même style
c'est la dernière fois que je le sais là
il va rendre et non non mais qu'est ce
que tu veux je ne mets que peut pas
bouger le pompage quoi sert il de crise
il voient pas que tu fais là qu'est ce
que je veux faire c'est eux c'est le
vois pas gagner c'est là peut-être
inventé un faux bond à 8 les nerfs
football pour ne pas voir le jeu le
chèque sur 2,8
ok mais ça tient peut-être ce truc là
encore non encore trouver une planque en
même pour gagner je connais pas doté le
nul théorique comme ça narnia pas nulles
tirer qu'ici c'est sûr mais il faut
encore trouver de manière de la manière
de guingois doctorat de win32 sa griffe
oui non oui ça guérit tout de suite est
plus vaste des attaques de votre ou vos
bois et je pense avec les blancs je suis
toujours chez jamais il faut jouer vite
ou pas dans cette position là qu'on le
méritait pas non mais c'est incroyable
et ça c'est pas maintenant est ok mais
assure pas d'idées
ok veut faire h4 ces machins des
fougères
mais c'est un crâne quand même comment
ils galèrent games a donc pourquoi il a
bouffé surtout 6 attentes en mai c'est
nul maintenant y avait foule et 6 food
et 6 7 nuls tu peux pas empêcher roi
prend je pense
après cette affaire quatre mois
maintenant et quand même un an oui mais
maintenant avec l'option suffira g4
c'est une théorie oui oui ça ça je suis
d'accord
une fois le plus urgent 3 et s'il vous
est bien toi ça c'est une âme et ça
saigne sommes donc le pied sur age 2 x 5
et c'est un faux jeu trois chèques alors
ça va être à nous le dire est nul bon
moi peut-être quelqu'un m'a pas cru
quand je dis vous parler du niveau
non mais là c'est grave quand même la
note pour la peine mec est fou c'est
cette moindre et les gueux le dommage
est malin mais si on va les voir
maintenant le courage de 800 et nous et
en plus au moment le plus marquant du
match jusqu'à présent arrivée de poids
ouais mais pourquoi tu rigoles poil et
âme tout le monde de réguler à la rocky
elle joue son truc préféré dans votre
oiseau 20 16 non mais ça tout commence
avec la tour qui est revenue 1,8 et
oubliez pas de soutien sur 3 4 h 30
bah oui oui bah je sais pas comment
c'est possible qu il l'a pas fait je
comprends en fait non mais c'est dingue
mais peut-être speeches 0,6 non je sais
pas mais c'est fou tout cela aussi est
ce qu'ils jouent pas ce qu'implique un
blitz que c'est ce soit quoi non plus
sinon qu'il en mêlée ils connaissent
aucune théorie en finale et ont réussi à
attendre un hello hello de dingue ça
prouve le talent de ouf qu'ils ont ça
prouve sa peut-être ça prouve quelque
chose
mais là ça c'est extraordinaire ce que
même devoir blad la partie de la
champagne ou un tel truc rire du pire
jeter tipi 19,83 pas 90 93 83
comme c'est mignon ou pour les premières
fois dans le club va faire des prix de
mots jetés pour une partie donc non plus
trop pousser les pions h c'est connu que
c'est pas bon dans la finale de tout à
l'heure si tu au lit les livres sur les
finales où j'adorais au lieu de faire le
poulet non mais ça c'est connu ça même
moi je savais c'est fou quoi
mais le pire tu sais c'est qu'on va t on
voir voile ça non désolé je pensais que
force est d'oublier que la dame des
ambiances 6 mai mais tu sais je pense
que s'il rejoue la même finale dans un
an il sera toujours pas comment gagner
des telles regarde pas après leur parti
possible tu prends des caractères chose
qu'il cannes vous ébrouer voir sur la
russie a tient mais comment ça c'est tu
sais pas qu'il faut pas pousser le prix
oseo jusqu'aux trois français dans le
bouquin de varetz khider mais parmi les
connaissances
le général que tu prends tes le début
c'est au début de chaque chapitre sur le
chemin qu'on croise à éviter ça parfois
il ya des positions compliquées quand
t'en fous une autre à un tour est un
pion est le pionner fcs est très dur de
à dire est-ce que ça gagne ou non c est
faire de sa canne ou pas parfois bon
avec le pion est gelée qui aurait très
connu en fait je pense que une fois le
pionner sur quatre s'est déjà souvent là
sauf si le roi est sûre l'histoire sont
rois a été sur ce toit il est pas
content il n'est pas trouvée
quand même comment il fallait gagner et
donc maintenant se posent les boissons
notre mobile écoutez poubelles ne sont
pas sans savoir qu'un homme de belle
partie aujourd'hui des bons partir ok ce
n'est que la troisième donc non on a
toujours près de redonner à rigoler mais
on va voir quand même des bons partis
s'opposent celle là aujourd'hui pour moi
n'a pas de chance parce que ma meilleure
offre so c'était la pire green shoots
est même vert et rouge s'était pas fou
c'était pas top
ok c'était pas six mois les prix tout
mais c'était pas trop depuis un moment
demandé lundi qu'on a piloté la médecine
ont moqué les plupart du temps c'est
resté de leur monnaie sauf que ici
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent c'était bien de quoi
mais peut-être avant tout eux devront se
chauffer et jouer comme je serais le
premier à vous et 4 rebonds
comme maire je sais je sais je s'opposer
et qu'est-ce qui accueille 4 avec les
dédales justice ah ouais
c'est joli ça
c'est ce que s'est passé non non il a vu
où ça maintenant voyez de kyzyl gilles
comment savoir quand même des trucs il a
view ça est donc maintenant et il s'y
dit quoi faire parce qu'ils étaient les
miennes quoi colère je sais que les
arcades
je sais pas je sais même pas comment en
fait se défendent
jefferies peut-être mais l'accord est de
6 km mais je suis comme en sept mois en
confiant pour parham et non pas l'autre
est capable d un truc pas rama trop
optimiste le dos nu salles différentes
c'est une grosse défense tient mais
qu'est ce qui a préparé caraïbes 4 mais
est ce que l'autre à vue
en d'autres termes nous souhaitons nous
envoie pas quelque chose
vas-y fais collège gaza
cela répond à cette première ligne de
leurs décomptes habitudes comme vous
entourent enfin c'est pas la praline de
leur disent que c'est parce qu'ils
proposaient mais après il comprend quoi
parce que leur vie a du mal à van damme
pranger 6 avec peu de profondeur
c'est dommage que tu sois fort bon
maintenant ce serait pas mal de
transférer une autre pièce lourde sur la
troisième soit la tour soit là dedans 5
je sais pas si précieux parce que j'ai
fait sans que les 5 de notre arthur
bourgeois que vous le fîtes binger bien
simplifié le truc quand même
ok que les filles et dames si c'est vrai
je suis moins bien d'accord mais j'ai
bien simplifié les pauses comme quand
même donc 5 c'était loi minimaliste
telma minimaliste c'est bien sûr pas
corrigé 5 3 5 mais même ça c'est
possible d'ailleurs qu'au volet social
sur la 56e était possible et 6e
je comprends qu'il y ait des quatre avec
les deux dames 4e série damages 5
oh oui il appelait les oubliés peut-être
que dans le 4 3 ap adam au sein d'un
mauvais ok mais d'autres manières en a
compris qu avec ces deux là ne peut pas
être choqué de quoi que ce soit tout
permis quoi tout est permis aujourd'hui
vendredi tout est permis
vous bien car ici on parle assez
aujourd'hui c'est ma mère crédit et aux
thérapies ces jeux dirigeants jeudi le
jeu gagne et tout est permis
et en plus les arts et les autres
exemples et moi du temps pour richard
curtin nous nous verrons mais le temps
que lama est l'hôte
non mais moi ce qui ce que je joue aussi
en profiter pour dire blad c'est de voir
la force aussi des mecs du top niveau
quand je commentais avec maxime puisque
maxime en fait ils hallucinent quand il
commande c'est comme ça en fait maxime
ils hallucinent sur quasiment chaque
coup
parmi eux il ya deux gâteaux quoi et en
fait je disais à maxime quand je
commente avec lui j'ai justement ça
montre aussi la différence de niveau est
énorme entre des mecs qui sont 50e 60e
mondiale et les mecs du top s'est lui
amélioré 90e donc moi ouais mais les
différences quelles normes de nouveau
comme état était 18e mondiale et du raid
ou quoi tu as plus de force intrinsèque
que mais j'ai en fait la différence
allait cosmique bon l'air celui ci
votre camp buts et le noir en fait je
crois devrait être en faute
mais comment afin de procéder à oui je
vois d'orage 3 juillet dans le cadre
bien sûr c'est que les 115,4 ce que je
sais que vous connaissez et qui
finalement est la vie et si on faisait
ça marche sans qui s'est finalement
élevée ou encore des saints finalement
elle avait eu la réponse est scrutin ils
sont forts si si
maroc et non j'ai voulu faire semblant
que ça fait bien non pour ce truc ça va
pour gagner du crunk de plus ces
attaques
ça rappelle aujourd'hui
ah bon en avion ça pendant la première
partie
et puis donc la tentative pervers taux
met à le coller sur ce il reçoit sa
cette fois ci ibuka d'un c'est à dire
que le vainqueur et blanc a compris
tiens tiens
il a fallu au cercle en attendant ce
sens qu'ils n'en fit brisa gillet
m'attendais ils connaissent et
maintenant elle chiale
pourquoi j'ai pas envie de le dire toi
tu sais lui s'est passé 2009 elles
étaient les françaises une chanson de
rap et chanson de rap
ok je peux le dire c'est pas vulgaire et
les non dits pauvres mais les
spectateurs que ce point nous tient au
fait messieurs les anciens c'est la paix
donc relève de deux chiens qu'il booste
booth de la créativité
moi j'aime bien les noirs mais qui
n'aime pas ça comme ça ok la tête faut
prendre un à trois rames en mai tandis
est indécis c'est surtout parce que dans
pas d'autant c'est donc les moquées
obligés de jeu call of duty free de
cette 2è tour du web est normalement et
faut deux à six as et cinq sages avaient
vu ces cinq mais je pensais qu'il y
avait tant à force de voir ça je te
viande ridiculement bas je pensais faire
ici des cdc
non en fait d'un v6 justement il a loupé
face à chrome os est peut-être dame c5
direct dans ce sens ben ouais ce drame
serge tu observes de sept jours
non dans cet opus est une chose trop de
jours injouable
ok domicile se pratique ce coup du point
très pratique
donc attend un hic les caméras ah oui on
a notre caméra car un tout petit peu
mise comme ça alors à temps du coup j'ai
ma bouteille en fait je vais la rampe ya
[Musique]
donc bon maintenant j'aime bien les
blancs maintenant j'aime bien les
besoins
je sais pas à quel point son mieux mais
bien sûr mieux et très confortable
région pour le point débuter ou se perd
mais là c'est pas une faute grave des
noirs
non ok ça reste dans les normes et les
terres quoi bon mais c'est assez
désagréable dans le dos à trois points
possibles comme le 4 po cisco l'histoire
autour de quatre enfants
c'est un vrai régal est surtout parce
que le fou sur scène il faut encore
ordinateur et joue un jouet neuf si ce
fou ça ressemble à des anglaises
maintenant koléa secrètes sont pas du
tout je ne vois pas pourquoi une bourse
propres pièces quoi hein mais pourquoi
et beaucoup
ce propos ce matin donc c'est 6 ok mais
les bons sauts mieux quand même bien sûr
moitié soit dans votre soit urbain
ok d'un bandeau se bricole histoire
épique avec diane ça marche pas du tout
je vais pas quelques la justice c'est
pas décollé de 5 x 222 5e lewis espère
aider dans vos jeux 6-2 6-4 et prend dès
3h poids d'un enfant met au ban de toute
manière c'est ça ça quand c'est avoir un
bon avantage pour les banques
parce que bon on a tous les atouts je
vais devoir jouer un nouveau vocabulaire
416 away ou avoir oui c'était possible
pour faire réfléchir
maintenant il ya plus maintenant à bien
sûr possible sur baissiers se trouve au
sud tous dessus faut pas réfléchir et
pour fixer à vie ok il a vu le truc
tactique qui aurait il menace de cinq
mois ça je peux dire ça oui la vie donc
même pas elle gagne plus
budaj aux cinq sens pas je me trompe
donc je vais été dépêche un bon savoir
faire quoi alors de demi de salaire 3°
taris corps lablad 3 2 hangars regarde
un risque assez calme
bon maintenant mais en fait non c'est un
lieu que les taux ce nu c'était qu'un
des deux ce serait pénible quoi nous
avait surtout mis au jour ce que leur
nullité et plus ou moins égales ouais
c'est ça ce que ma se servent d'un geek
c'est un match intéressant du nom si les
deux ce nul c'est fantastique c'est
comme les films pour rien dit un succès
ouais quand tu rigoles comment nous faut
aller ça a été le moteur truc préféré
lorsque matériaux sont allés sur un film
à dire complètement pourri et de gaulle
est composé d eau pendant 2h12 mince à
karbala le site
c'est que des mecs ça exceptionnel
ces dépôts pire extrait du signal et
mais qui consacrent leur journée à faire
des compilations de film va donc faut
alors envoyé ce magic n'en resta pas de
bol la psy la personne qui fait l'équipe
rebelles parlent aux gens qu'on aime
parler de l'erreur de débutant car les
géants parle jouent comme des types le
temps joue je vous parle d'eux comme de
débutants sinon je peux parler d'eux
comme de jeunes ici
s'ils font ce que des trucs de génie
mais je dis ce que je vois est excusé et
tu vois c'est le problème du fait que le
deuxième sera donné à tout le monde
il ya trop de j'aime ces mecs ne sont
pas des athlètes relate des pitres ouais
c'est pas d'épitaphe au départ mais je
pense que là la diète de maxime jousse
est pas la diète de peter pot de départ
têtu fille sur install puis tapotez pas
n'ont pas détruit sur install ouais
ouais
ce mec est un la tête qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ma main un mauvais film ouais
c'est un film pourri mais pourri à tel
point qu'il en devient bon où est
heureux en fait il en devient bon un
amas doivent donc voilà le match de
manière il ya un troll de je pense dans
les nanas vous pourrez regarder - troll
de tana pas mal the room room c'est un
classique
tommy wiseau mais le mec il a fait du
pognon grâce à son fils et moi il est nu
quelques nanars sens plus fort
américaine et iranienne
il paraît que c'est très difficile de
faire un bon nanar parce que si tu le
fais exprès en fait c'est une annonce tu
le fais exprès c'est nul parce que
justement elles exprimeraient va être
drôle ouais
du coup tu fais une espèce de gad
elmaleh si tu veux à gad elmaleh
j'ai vu un article dans le figaro
attention à où il disait gad elmaleh il
prenait les français n'aiment plus les
humoristes a carrément brisé combattant
tout le monde se méfie depuis les
affaires de plagiat toute façon peu
importe c'est juste pour dire j'ai vu
même un article pour dire que les
humoristes ne font plus rire les poumons
c'est ou c'était quelque chose comme ça
bon c'est bien fini
ouais il va la gagner mais un vrai
nanami la gagne pas un vrai nanar sa
verve reynard selamat la partie buzz
contre elle utilisera sa vraie d'un art
qui se termine par un
bon non vraiment c'est la partie j'avais
fait deux pages et commencer une partie
de gens qui suivent la chaîne et il y
avait une dame de plus puis une dame de
moins puis une dame de plus ça finit par
pat à la fin ça ça à brennan a donc tu
veux dire que ça c'est pire quand même
bien c'est des nanars et the way et ça
tue un peu le match au final tient le
vrai nanar faut tu vois là on se
demander ce qu'ils font pas exprès ça on
ne sait pas est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
aussi nul que ça où ils font exprès que
le match arrangé
est ce que rennes chez venus payer donne
un billet pour que ça joue comme ça
quand on ne sait pas là maintenant on
est dans le doute tu vois le vrai d'un
arbre ça vous mal à fond là on sait plus
de 3 jamais il refait sais tu vas base
sur une analyse de sa partie mais cela
montrerait le boss tu veux qu'on analyse
sa sortie ouais très intéressés
tu avais dit j'avais plus temps sinon
joue à 2003 les scop l'add on peut faire
vous aussi soif 7
parce qu'en face au vent ne s'est même
pas un jour insiste bien sur les noirs
jour 2 5 à 3 j'ai six faux jeu cette
fois eu six paires logique de faire si
cette terre quand il ya un seul joueur
four qui a joué la belge
donc c'était moi la duke je reconnais
que s'il faisait rire et les faisait ça
souvent moi je pense qu après saint
cloud ce sein que de ça que c'est pas le
top pour moi je préfère je suis tiens
c'est marrant parce que ils disent que
c'est guy ricky qui commente avec rage
et du coup on pourrait faire le t-shirt
s'ils n'avaient pas mais ça va super
bien pour les noirs non
c'est pas compris poule 6
beke dans ce match est un peu de chose
que je comprends mais en fait c'est pas
bizarre de faire autant d'efforts pour
prendre le mauvais bout ça reste
toujours d'aller visiter
malgré tout malgré tout je pense que moi
que vous êtes un grand favori j'ai bien
définis avant parfois les trop
optimistes
mais l'autre fou je sais pas mais à
rudolph hess qu'il faut fournir 12
faible et l'appareil alors que navarra
fou oui il a de nouveau un statut et il
sait pas tenir la pause et les pratiques
de nos instincts empli de sa fin je
pense que c'est entre un programmateur
jeu un cadastre racing j'ai vu ces
partis quand même mais je pense qu au
blitz s'est passé mais c'est le truc de
qui vous moquez en connaîtrons tous de
bons joueurs ils sont tellement nombreux
et exemple ok oublions les joueurs de
l'étoile
bien sûr corbeau excellent madoff
excellent excellent
à temps aux oignons vladimir excellent
112-1 kurian non permanents petrosyan
d'être aussi un excellent excellent
c'est clair
donc moi ils sont nombreux marseille 9
jan non sourire je connais pas juste
nous sommes très nombreux à sanaa
mec de saratov
pourtant c'est bien et elle ouvrit
toujours était il est toujours dur de
dire qu'est ce que les bleus avec mam
était très bien
les golden boys en advienne il est super
bien ben justement bartik bord tenir
donc vous voyez donc se fout pas la
gueule de tout le monde que du respect
pour les anciens n'a pas que des anciens
partis n'gahane a redit ce qui est en
cause comme le nom mais je vois pas
comment je pense qu'ils jouent mieux que
par la blessure à 10 h membre honoraire
les 3100 où 350 par mm3 ses 1000 points
mais sans point de plus que par un
nomade général j'ai toujours pensé que
les américains ont une bonne crise j'ai
toujours pensé c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que c'est tellement surprise parce que
joueuse parce que ce que je vois je
pense que n'importe quel y remet bien
ambriz il aurait dû créer lui mais je
suis sûr
donc s'ils n'ont pas ce qu'on voit sur
l'échiquier écoutez je sais pas tu vas
dire je pense qu'à exploser mon égard
mais peut-être que je me trompe durée de
1 h 6 pions servirait de terrain
faiblesse mais je pense que c'est trop
dur d'exploiter ça c'est trop dur de le
prouver
donc je pense que c'est plus ou moins
les gains en fait moi je ne sais pas si
je resterai à toi même tu t'intéresses 3
sais pas vous mais moi je l'aurais pas
fait je serais quelque chose me
dépouille d'un souk ou peut-être parce
que les bons ouvre les positions et
c'est normal que je viens de faire le 5
mais moi je n'aurais pas fait ça c'est
sûr moi je refuse je crois et j'aurais
commencé les opérations sur les routes
de l'aude a donc ça m'a détruit la
partie voir montrer si j'ai raison bacon
au maximum recommence de pousser des
gueules je pense que parce que trois
c'était mali c'est génial comme argument
est foutu avec les têtes qui foetus est
plus ou moins ce qui se passe quand pas
sûrement sur l'échiquier mais ce qui se
passe dans sa tête
j'ai rien fait roi prend 1,6 regardez
tous rêvent cette tour je cède à poc poc
erreur cinq touches rock ac grâce ne
donnez jamais voir des détonateurs touré
font croire 6 pourquoi pas m'acheter mon
pour kilea ya deux minutes et demie mais
c'est quelque chose
c'est quelque chose auquel récepteur je
sais te réussit ce qui serait plus de
revenus quoique les noirs pour continuer
ma voix je sature et c'est sale ça va
perdre un pion ils vont perdre un
deuxième un troisième donc et bien sûr
ses fours se fout du monde
donc si on va gagner c'est moi j ça va
être la meilleure à liszt illustration
du principe
faites gaffe ou céder de l'autre la peur
parce que max lawson body coup droit et
elle m'a à chaque fois mais au moins il
joue son jeu mais c'est pas les montées
bon maintenant à l'autre peut être
espèrent surtout cette fausse au 7e tour
à cette dernière partie ce qui est
marrant c'est très intense et 7 pouces
et 7 c'est un peu bizarre non donc je
veux dire plus ils ont accompli un
nourrissage oublier l'obliqué au f4
contrôle sur sept nous arrive encore les
seydoux mais qu'est ce que c'est
esthétique
pourquoi pas tour à 7 pour moi c'est dur
à comprendre
ok mais il va les taper les pions un
lecavalier quoi pourquoi pas non dougan
ici bien sûr mais maintenant elle est
drôle et au noir qui médit les
l'esthétique le mec nous pas mal c'est
fait
ok aussi ici tu préfères monza au sort
que ça montre que les faibles parce que
cannes en course américaine cherche pas
de telle manoeuvre abstraite à la can
dance qui quoi carré noir quoi bbbb
jamais citer tous les peintres russes
maintenant à toi et te savais que gary
gray
je pensais que c'était malevitch ou
comment il s'appelle à un nom café noir
c'est moi levi chevaux mari j'ai oublié
aucun disque quelques esquisses et
d'autres choses excuse pas de chance
mais c'est peut-être qu'ils ne voulaient
pas de contredire tu vois mais sur l'eau
que je reste un peu après un repas trop
plein et tu as dans le chat qui font les
malins maintenant mais il savait pas non
plus tu vois j'ai posé ma culture sur le
chat jeu tu vois je dis rien j'arrive je
pose mes couilles malevitch dans ta
gueule
kandinsky ses trucs de couleur fou c'est
plus une amarre j'ai confondu le non non
non qu'on y skie c'est navarra de la
peinture c'est fou mais j'aime bien mais
j'adore chagall du seigneur qui est un
super musée chagall paris 6 paris sud
qui a été peint par jallet se passe ici
sait pas où mais en plus c'est musée
chagall à nice fantastique fantastic
je recommande ce a fait une adresse en
plus pour le chat on sait jamais si vous
êtes marié disent ouais non tu as
beaucoup lu bouafi connais très très
beau tu vois non c'est magnifique
il n'y a pas cinq villes qu'est ce que
tu penses est-ce que avec ça si je mets
un t-shirt vert ce qui est faux oui
sinon tu vas te fais ça chauffe la blanc
en fait à l'exil en blitz si tu perds
jamais l'espoir si tu la perds il te le
rend assez sympa le prix du métal sur
leur foi parce que c'est le capriotti
chose que j'ai acheté il ya deux jours
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le troisième trailer
nouveau tee shirts
est-ce que ça gagne
bac 4 2 ok maintenant faut bouger
papy le papier bref cette suffisant et
oui avec lyon que tu perds jamais
l'espoir qu'elle s'est pas fait en un
jour
qu'est ce qu'il faut voir c'est elle qui
prend son temps en tout cas à temps mais
que tu peux faire
tu peux faire le tour de cette aussi que
vous les filles trouvent ça qu'elle
voulait de 7,4 que réussie soit 3 à yako
les deux sets de khalis à 80
ça ne peut pas sauf que tu mets locaux
volée sur un iphone il dit quand même à
la fin mais bon bref cette explication
toute simple de hockey ça ne s'enseigne
pas loin et développer c'est pas nul ça
mais je vais avoir prédit qu il faudra
regarder trois remixes mais ok c'est
gagné attends ce pas surtout réussi ce
fou dit au post crise et on attend mais
avec tout réussit sa non s'appelle ok
mais tout n'est pas joué et les jo mais
en fait ce que différents entre nos 2 e
ceux qui ont continué de jouer de telles
positions
à risque et ça peut marcher ça
arriverait non mais j'ai déjà perdu
contre tel truc tu sais juste que je
tiens à temps parce que je pense que
même à abandonner le fameux livre
s'appelait 19,84 oui moi je dis 19 83
quand j'ai fait mon premier pas dans le
groupe de chez c'est là où je vais mais
c'est harry sial grave à l'éthique
utopie quoi mais bon tout ça ma langue
j'inventais qui sait pas la tour en 1
c'était une tentative d'arnaqué on a
compris en fait le charpentier c'est un
mec très spécial dans le chat parce que
enfin ils auraient fait des études de
psychologie il serait traducteurs mais
il sera incapable de traduire oralement
servier dit que c'est différent
traducteur interprète donc en gros on
est sûr que quelqu'un qui est plus ou
moins psychologiquement instable et il
nous fait croire qu'il est traducteur
aquilée psycho il a fait les études le
genre je lui ai dit mais tu es marié
avec emilie rajad cops qui est tout ça
il était disait que c'était vrai quoi il
s'appelle le sharp ont du coup on sait
pas vraiment qui c'est en fait mais on
pense que ça un déséquilibré on pense à
céret schizophrène c'est juste pour
t'expliquer le personnage fait tu vas
souvent le voir dans le chat en fait
donc là c'est pour que tu s'il écrit des
trucs
peut-être qu'il est grand mais tu vois
on sait pas que je suis au près sa
peinture cambridge qu'après sa partie ça
voulait plutôt fou
bon apparemment fidèle à son style donc
les rouges au collet 3 3 il le fait
toujours avec ses trois ou quatre mois
délai c'est bon pour l'instant rien à
critiquer par contre normale sauf qu a
précédé les bras les leurs sont tout à
fait ok mais ça va quand on voit donc
pas commencé de se [ __ ] de leur gueule
maintenant parce que ok pas très
critiquable est d'ailleurs le sco aurait
des surprises
là je pense que toute légalité
peu importe quel coup de feu faux ce
qu'interdit 3 à fuji 4 il faut qu'on
n'était pas mieux pour les blancs n'ont
pas vraiment de justement parce que 2,4
être oublié si les puits en eaux très
peu 3,2 mio pour les bons mais les plus
anciens de 4 à 3 non ce qui en fait
c'est le thème d'un point de version
pour faire simple 2006 que le 4-4-2
cavale a non excusez-moi je me trompe
mais pour ce créateur de toi tu peux
faire facilement sans risquer quoi que
ce soit les douanes vont encaisser les
opinions avec photos d'autres
franchement fou de toi même temps que tu
fais connaissez ce curieux
peut-être relever le faire après avoir
bougé l'être tout ça se cache sûrement
c'est pas un peu trop fins trois fois
mon coup tout est validé
sauf que ça m'étonnerait à aller à vau
peut-être il a enfin il a forcé de jouer
tous un petit trafic et de catherine de
joe cole et le sang qui craignent d'être
aie aie aie pour chanter le goût de
trucs mais au tour 3 il faut bouge
quelque part pour jeu que les cadres en
forme c'est guy bien france s'il le fait
ce que c'est c'est très fin 45 de
retrouver voie de je pense qu'il a tout
vu avec des thèmes comme lui c'est que
de la chance il n'a pas encore montré
les signes d'une alarme temps ok il veut
dire que six f4 peut-être dame office 9e
2 e collège de fouquereuil parce que ça
a été très fort mural d'un v6 f-22 que
les ce2 faut que trois ça il peut voir
des trucs ça et ça ça les salaires très
bien pour la wii dans ce col à un
respect énorme parce qu il a commencé
avec fois de bon ça va c'est en fait une
bonne partie graphique est ce que je
veux faire ma main et je voudrais que ce
soit les noirs qui gagne pardon pourrait
que ce soit vision qui gagne la partie
quoi
dans ce sens que tu entends un moment
donné pour pousser h 4 et 6 4
parce que là les palestiniens ça marche
très souvent ça et h4 collège local et
et ses dires de jouer ce traité c'est
pas correct juste neuf mois comme ça je
vois pas pourquoi cela parce que sinon
mais les noirs doivent se calmer un peu
parce que fo a d'autre joue pas car mon
fils tu qu'ils ont commencé bon ce sa
faiblesse les rôles et confignon
jefferies ah oui ce que montrent les
marques du temps l'un pro league au
final c'est c'est le signe typique de
les marques du temps parce que les gros
talent
les chioukhs en vrai elle joue bon bout
mais c'est arrivé au palis me laisser de
bons visé les positions et les petits
joueurs c'est toujours les petits coups
vous les majeures il sent pas le rythme
de la lutte mais c'est dur de sentir
mais justement c'est pour ça qu'il faut
apprendre les partis des meilleurs
joueurs du monde pour ça tire le rythme
car les positions de déséquilibrer les
déséquilibres est ici qui rassemble
plutôt terre appartient pourrait les
pauses fois de maintenant pas au bon
moment parce que les branches ont
[Musique]
sûrement d un type d'hôtes
peut-être qu'à relief 5
mais je ne vois pas comment justifier
s'achève à dix au bout faisant dam d'un
bonjour je vois pas comment justifier à
6 juillet non ça marche pas voilà donc
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait ici écoutez
je pense que quand vous l'êtes de deux
suffisant parce que si qu'heureux les
sécateurs je bous sûr je sais tu es ici
comme l'e3 et fera je sais de damages
échec à je mentirai pas je règle je vous
demande marc dutroux prades
oui mais bien sûr c'est trop fort pour
eux donc il va avoir notre cour - enfin
enfin les vosges et pas avant oui voilà
[Rires]
c'était pas mal
tiens c'est bien de se sentir jour grâce
à eux je les aurais bien encaissé à tam
à l'époque je pense qu'un bon forme
serait et épique very big ben est ok je
dis c'est trois ou we do pas mal peine
c'est un beau massacre mais je pense que
je rêve mais je fais ça à toutes les
compagnies des jeunes talents à moscou
du faisceau contre qui je veux pas dire
le nombre parce que c'est pas que ray
mais il ya 400 kg fait ça à toutes les
banques compagnie des gens
je veux pas citer les nombreuses zones
domicile je veux pas ok mais ils sont
plus forts que 2626 60e
on va parler je pense il ya 4 5 ans
si tu les avais mis quand toutes sans
exception ils avaient qu'à l'âge
a donc c'était bien oui moi parce qu'ils
ont tous démissionné
oui mais c'est comme à dire c'est plus
ou moins lié au niveau que les mecs
montrent que c'est un vin d'honneur
était bien prévisible et tu commences
comment je doutais à sec à chaque fois
parce qu'avant on donnait commencent les
tu vois ça les conneries qu'ils font en
étuve eu vent des mecs de ce niveau
manar après trois ans d'arrêt si tu
jouer maintenant contre des joueurs de
bon matin je pense que je peux club
contre qui que ce soit à la plage a dit
assurant est peut-être n'importe qui bon
les menaces à dame de sang donc pas tant
pour fois je suis soit juste un des cinq
tours 17
mais plus je deviens c'était karen
autour de cette danse est intéressant je
suppose que c'était très intéressant
pour recharger les dames
parce que collet je sais qu'ils
participent pas dans les courses de
pinot noir ce qui prime c'est aussi
direct avant intermédiaires qui est
intéressant on peut importe maintenant
c'est les noirs qui vont gagner parce
que le pion c'est trop fort non ok et
son seul à décider de cette inspiration
bref cette dame aussi c'est qu'on voit
des tarer à perpète se sont soldées sauf
que ça m'étonnerait sa motoneige adamo
suite du bourget sera inhumé dans fais
toi c'est le plus facile
ça c'est pas trop dur non plus quoi elle
avec deux dames tu fais dame 17 damage 3
ha tiens donc pour la première fois dans
le match que les américains voient mais
ouais ouais montrent au moins sept ou
pelé la branche on valoir quand il perd
il est complètement dans un bus sur le
bureau vingt mille ou moins fort non
c'est ça son problème bon intéressant
donc 4 à 3 c'est la dernière partie en
cinq plus un fait plus mais j'aurais
quand même très étonné de voir une
victoire de geffry un tout petit je
pense âgé de 55 ans ok avoir je donnais
j'ai pas 80% pour marceau de nous n'a
pas jo dont 70 même moi non non soixante
dix quand même qu'il va gagner quand
même lot elle est rustique
à chaque fois les politiques cherchent
trop mais je vois il ya un stade ou au
lac une dame en a cinq
donc j'estime mois serait plus un an et
demi plus d'eau plus trois de jeu ouais
c'est ça qui va arriver quoi que ce soit
mais la dame et je suis permettre la
santé la situation mais il comprend pas
les autres juste mais les basses 20
heures par jour oui mais quoi ça sert si
tu arrive toujours pas c'est avec au
bout du sig où il a déjà qu à 7,12 les
règles du jeu positionner une après
l'autre
l'une après l'autre mais il est en train
de refaire les théories positionner
distinguer quoi sert de bar à ma part je
vieux kick ass qui fait sa force alors
si fait de si grosses erreurs et il doit
avoir un potentiel énorme
tout ce que je veux dire à présent comme
nous mais comme un trait de très près
aux résultats a voce classique
je pense juste quand il est mauvais on
glisse pas ce que fait trop boulette
je me réserve à ça je dis rien d'autre
je dis pas qu aux
au croisic quoi que ce soit j'ai vu
aussi partie saleh après d'être très
très impressionnant
d'accord mais en plus il est bien faible
c'est tout ce que je vois disons les
instances sont mauvais chez l'un et chez
l'autre parce que jouer comme ça la bhf
5,2 5,6 dame à saint lô
j'aimerais mayotte électrostatique
double brin pourquoi pas jusqu'à dire
trois fois oui
ces parcours tantôt boire ça montre
qu'ils les entendent pas ce qu'on a dans
l'école normale de secours ne rate pas
tu souffres mais en fait ce qui est
incroyable dans le show de ce soir qui
ont le mieux réussi 2 randomisée
complètement les échecs racing chaque
partie est durant donfut cher pourtant
ça commence avec les pauses normal même
si beaucoup de coups énormes
à chaque fois la poste numéro 9 960
mais il arrive foot je le pose 430 crise
est déjà 500 de sofame qua non oui oui
c'est intéressant
soyez 1970 la justice vous êtes
magiciens
ouh là donc il a commencé avec la belge
il a continué avec le gambit dos dames
et maintenant il veut donc est en dix
ans dialysé n'importe quoi non aux
spectateurs ont tout à fait raison les
maisons de jeunes et l'achat galles et
l'autre est donc mal et malevitch ou est
en fait oui aujourd'hui en fait c'est
une séance de jeudi qu aurait scellé
sciences de thatcher spéciaux et ça ça
vous vois ça deux jours
et puis pouf dû rouvrir
et puis un peu de laque sur brive 5e et
prendra huit ans
tiens
nous les français on adore les
impressionnistes quoi la pensée de
l'impressionnisme fut très impressionné
[Rires]
sauf qu'eux ne pas parce que jouer avec
ses 5 et b france intéressant écoutez
vous dire par rame faible en blitz et
les 3000
je me rappelle menchov trash connaissent
un jour de macédoine un moment donné sur
ay si si ils avaient 3675 il est si fort
que ça oblige aussi vous voulez dire
investir ici beaucoup sur chaise quand
même peut-être me rappelle de cette
époque et trash connais ma dernière il
est vrai se gausse ma surprise sur l'iss
auxerre
mais j'ai l'impression qui s'en est pas
mal sorti par am
ça aurait pu être beaucoup pire
sauf que je pense pas que l'église va
faire beau c'est maintenant je suppose
c'était ce bref au bout cette d'un bus
est le terreau espère que les plaintes
de trois tombes c'est pas sûr que oui
peut-être les raisons de ce calibre
c'est faux c'est 4 5 et 3 7 oui ce sera
ce que j'espère mais je m'en doute que
c'est pas un gamin ok il a trouvé une
des parties qu après ce but moi je vois
pas encore moins tout intérêt à joindre
à l idée qu est ce que les noirs ont
donc sauvé le pion de 3 après avoir
perdu perdu le foot ce qui sonne à son
tour toute manière les bliss que les
bois risquent rien du tout toujours est
d'amd 6 reprend ici et c'est vrai pour
un sac
ok peut-être tu vois là tu vois le faire
mais tu vas bientôt quand même car avec
un but de kembo 5e tour mais cherche un
peu de contre contre je non je comprends
en lui-même d'ailleurs
à grasse qui font reculer leurs
waterschei ans ils défendent leurs pions
navire que les retours fréquents de haut
h7 que les 2,7 pareil et donc préparant
que c'est le pion avec lui aux cavaliers
ou les dents tombent et 5 par exemple
ok parham a pas trop bon dans besoins
pratiques rue 25e sac par contre il
faudra trouver le coup c'est l'idée ok
les niches choisies c'est du troll pas
ceux qui pensent que les lots de chasse
comme ça démontre quelque chose ça
démonte pas grand chose l'ue le sur jazz
ska pop art dont les lots sur jazz comme
ça démontre pas grand chose c'est à toi
de dire j'ai jamais fait sur le parti
sur ce coup je sais pas ouais je vois
qu'ils ont des sauts impressionnants
bleus jouent m'intéresse même oppression
pas du tout moi je pense qu'à partir de
cela à partir de 2007 2008
3000 faut enlever genres entre 250 et
300 points mais plus tu monde plus faut
enlever pour avoir l'équivalent en feed
donc j'aurais dit 3000 s'avoue 2007 en
gros non pas ramollo nauviale sortir là
maintenant c'est réparé en fait je pense
que 2700 et l'ofii dans blitz ça me
choque pas tu vois ça me choque pas
parce que tu vois même s'il fait des
trucs un peu bizarres ou quoi déjà tête
il n'est pas en forme d'aile à des
problèmes de connexion donc ça
déconcentre quand même d'être déconnecté
un billet sur 6 ou le cas bien sûr il a
des parents des lycéens fleurs dit à une
partie qu'ils avaient ri comme ça et
deuxièmement malgré tout même dans les
positions difficiles on voit qui calcule
bien il s'en sort bien quand même
aujourd'hui il a un peu de mal n'y a pas
de réussite ces problèmes de connexion
mais à part ça il n'est pas apte chose
que venir mais beaucoup d'infos et il
était aussi oui vraiment moi ici il
[ __ ] toujours groupe c'est bien
connecté bien sûr si sur lequel tu peux
jouer vraiment monnaie je sais ça
m'arrivait le pot
car ce beau que voulez vous c'est du rap
en noir d'autant way back autant
apprécié que tu trouves toujours sa
trame du récit
oui c'est ce que je dis non d'ici là il
a trouvé assez vite donc doué jeu ouais
ouais j'en fais la gueule même
l'impression comme ça il réussira à
merder donc normalement voir pierre
d'instruction 40 secondes presque
honteux presque vingt secondes toujours
pas très clair
ouais normalement avoir gagner bien sûr
mais ma vie au point de choses déjà là
mais moi je suis inquiète police sa
connexion tu vois là il est à trois
barres donc ça veut dire que c'est pas
excellent mais des fois il tomba de bach
donc ces radars partie de la cadence
vlad
en 3 + 1
mais ça ils devraient ce que vite parce
que après des oeillades à un échec
social ou sociétal
je ne sais pas si la wii pour les bords
faut 5 donc hélas prévu voilà élise ou
émet en speedo pas stable jusque là les
pommes il n'y a pas eu les idées de
l'autre une chance je préfère dame siens
et les deux pensent qu'il s'est juste
trompé d'or de coûts mais je pense que
si les dames c'est un roi bouger tes
deux je pense à gagner ça hein parce que
la dame de kazan dans tous les cas il
est bon ok sur internet c'est dur quand
à peu de temps franchement c'est dur non
non des sommets des critiques moi ça je
critique que ce que ça pour sa critique
de ses généraux non mais tu as il
acquiert un petit talent par am non
parfois une impression mais c'est
premier six coups sûrs et il a mérité
deux couples seulement
du coup on fait une pause 5 minutes a
tout de suite les spectateurs
[Musique]
pour les mecs on repart mais on sait pas
trop ce qui se passe ça repart au moment
où on lui dit tu vois c'est je fais pas
des trucs professionnel au au moins du
nouveau là elle va plus être si moh
moelle après l'ouverture un créatif donc
à nouveau le floch et au blad c'est
d'être dans des cas comme les c3 que
voler ou 4
car le cadre raté mais pas les bons
soirs mais le point le plus souvent dans
2 2 et puis tu fais qu'aller au judo que
le jeu et puis tu leur mets sur quatre
ans tout rond c'est un jeu auquel sans
jeu c'est important parce que c'est une
fable y es-tu vraiment ont collé sur
nous tous raza hockey vous savez très
bien ce que je vais dire je vous
parlerai pas
bon peut-être
ah oui ça permet de charger beaucoup des
pièces donc c'est pas le plus précis
quand j'ai montré le bon coup avec la
souris que le qatar je sais je sais que
locataire wabush que l'un des six sous 2
à 2,7 devient intéressant par contre
parce qu'après moi je sais tu que le cas
tu bouges rejouer présent et que les
décisions s'il faut jeter corps et celui
ci faubourg cette commission est fausse
et 6 ça sauve parce qu'il ya plus de
columbus
mais peut-être retourner dans mon coeur
mais ta fille peut-être autour de dôme
oui c'est possible parce que si après
comme les décisions je te mets à tanger
d'un 4 4 les faits d'armé trois thèmes
pour moi comme je souhaite est
intéressant vraiment puisque l'air
maintenant quand même pas beaucoup de
pièces ok ça c'est toujours eagles aucun
avantage maintenant pour le monde bien
sûr d'ailleurs plus facilement se
retrouver moins bien si les noirs
arrivent
habré que les six dames à saintes il
s'activait pour attaquer les pions et
ouais faut faire gaffe et s'il faut
faire gaffe très facile de revenir monde
puis parfois la voix est faible
après l'échangé des foules parfois à
cause des trop de faiblesses il faut
faire jouer les 3 et c'est encore une
fois une focus de plus d'un massage
consigne avait très bien joué parce que
c'est une prophylaxie contre damas a
donc si toi à huîtres élevées autour 7
et qu'on croirait un beau jouet comme g5
envisageable même si s'affaiblissant jeu
sans coller de 3
je vois pas comment continuer après
déjà peut-être il faut commencer
microïds pour que c'est plus un échec et
maintenant studieuse
donc moi je et alors seulement je sens
que petrov au but 5 et un blitz ça va
parler des quatre comtés pitié de ces
les plus grandes faiblesses d'options
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
quoi ils adorent faire voir passer les
coûts c'est toujours le signe d'un
manque total va jouer bien sûr ses
terres pour substantielle il peut être
juste un coup finit pas déjà et va le
perdre mais c'est dur semblant de passer
de ce niveau là celui là qu'est ce que
tu veux dur dur d'être bébé dur dur
d'être grand maître c'est moins dur dur
d'être une équipe et non mais je pense
que tu es bien comme ça non c'était une
tentative échouée du blog rich bayer un
truc comme ça s'est passé lors de
moments là tu dépasser ce point de
choses je sais que dans le sens où tu
voulais dire c'était pas méchant mais ça
peut être mal pris attention c'est pour
ça qu'il fallait pas trouvé ok h5 ne
s'appartient pas ici après avoir perdu
30 m pour nous mais si maintenant tout
est bon un peu joué donc c'est le pion
que je veux tenter quatre bijoux h4
aussi
donc
je vais appeler hacker prend des quatre
hectares bande des quatre et les drames
de 16 ans que je gagne de bio tombé 6
tu as fini là non bon tout le mal est si
bien sûr ok vous gérez fait au but 6
comme je pense parce qu'avec les des
dames de cette dame au 112 pour
l'histoire de fixer à prévoir à quatre à
cinq à six à sept à huit est d'ailleurs
après touba 6 dans nos 5 turbo il dérive
non mais c'est dur pour guillon qu'il
est quand même moins forme
vous savez pas la connexion je pense que
ce sera un massacre ok il va gagner bien
sûr mais si c'était plus clean quand
même mais bon ok je critique pas certain
quand même parce que te refile tour b65
tombe
ok alors on interview de richie mvele
avait le sentiment qu'après tour des 3
il avait probablement une victoire
possible pour les blancs on a parlé à
faire tout à l'heure flo vision du goût
c'est clair j'ai mes amis les
ordinateurs sur cette position
je pensais que ce pas la peine parce que
mais est ce qu ils étaient quelque chose
de la conférence de presse pourquoi le
jeu vous doute que nous on a tout
analysé quoi vous laisser les questions
pour vous les spectateurs et ce qu'elle
a dit quelque chose
ah tiens quand les jets si cette
esthétique roger 6 2004 et comme ce soir
bonsoir la compagnie ok mais là il veut
juste faire prise pris de risque et des
saletés voire des mois horribles et moi
je veux pour mémoire justement genre hey
vous faire d'emprunt pour madame un fils
je peux là en fait il n'y avait pas
juste d'un pont oui où
on a fait des petites flèches bad
ok mais bon ici c'est pardonnable
non tout gagné tout et tout et quand
même pas mais quand elle est mauvais il
est vraiment mauvaise bien car telle est
mort il est mort il est vraiment
amoureux jusqu'au bout de ses ongles
tu vas rire dans ce nom est dense plus
parham millavois 3 il a quand même l'air
super sympa
non c'est quelqu'un avec qui tu proposes
elle est dégoûtée à l'été connaît
quelque part doucement mais complètement
attend invite à examiner sur la plage le
routeur internet entend jouer les dates
j'ai rien compris aux dates en fait
parce que non il ya d'autres dates en
fait ils sont pas écrites mais c'est
bizarre par an pendant tout son match
précédent
il a joué cette ligne oui exemple n'a
même pas se préparer parce que ce qu'ils
jouent bien sûr ça peut donner aucun
drame tous les cas la prévision le truc
c'est qu'il a gagné mardi soir et qu'il
n'est que 24 heures pour se préparer à
peut-être pas eu le temps vous met une
heure suffit d'une heure suffit mais
c'est tellement c'était intéressant
comme on joue cette ligne ce que soit
fouet 3 c'est cool pour les noirs ou
qu'il est un foie et le pire du mois
s'écoulent comme voir cette fois ci
s'ajoutent résolu le problème pourquoi
spy cause elle te dis t'es mignon quand
tu souris vlad tu as un joli sourire
donc tu vois il écrit et du coup on a
réussi à découvrir que c'était une fille
elle n'avait jamais dit grâce à ça on
arrive cette année masset et dès que
celle qui écrit que signifie non c'est
moi qui est démasqué non mais c'est qui
est écrit que rien ne voulait sourire
mais bon je suis un cours deux fois plus
touchés
tu penses qu'on lui donner rdv gare
dissous oui c'est le mec qui fait
l'attraction mais jab série là qu'ils
demandaient au fake eusébia n'y fit oui
oui
écoutez p47 une ou deux fautes typique
dans cette position justement à cause du
beau 5 et puycalvel et précise que les
sécateurs très vite bkc bien sûr tant le
miniou mais pas comme les noirs peuvent
répondre 5
comme les peaux cisco l'escarcelle vlad
un truc que j'aime bien que ce plan b 5
c'est un des seuls que je connais contre
le pjd isolé et je le place tout le
temps et une fois tu sais ce que j'avais
contre meilleur j'ai fait le plan b 4 à
4 contre meilleur il m'a fait b5 mais
c'est à moi de jouer j'ai fait à 500
cavaliers jeanne d'arc
c'est un projet c'est qu'on a fait nul
du coup j'étais très heureux mais j'ai
dit quoi à 5 jeux pourquoi le plan
marche plus tiens voilà je vais sourire
ludwig je dis souvent qu'il ya quelque
chose de joli ou à oui oui oui oui
n'oublions pas où il est mais à 5
maintenant il se prend la même chose ça
ici non mais 26 à 5 c'est pas bête
c'est même obligatoire maintenant mais
comment tu l'as elle son problème alors
ceux qui ont hélas à tous sur le 8e fois
sur deux mais j'ai pas compris blatt
pourquoi à cavaler bicici pourquoi pas
qui a et b 6 6
abe avait fondé sa marche pas moi je
mange b5 wave 3 j f
j'ai pas le temps de faire des
carabistouilles mais du coup c'est une
grosse erreur
bon il va essayer maintenant de ramener
un autre cavalier sur ces 4 via des six
oui il ya plus d'autres moyens est-ce
qu'elle va réussir c'est intéressant
arsenal heureusement elle parle plus
quoi ben laden je sais un peu lent voilà
main alors voila tu sais ce que tu as
déjà pêché non point ce fonds ok je peux
de parra ok j'ai pas pêcher les poissons
d'accord mais quand tu vas perdre des
points des mets pas les tons plus quand
tu paie chèrement hyper important le
moment le plus important c'est quand tu
faire le poisson le moment le poisson
mord son hameçon et il ya un petit geste
à la main à faire on très technique pour
le chopper c'est un peu dégueu bien sûr
parce que tu m'aies hockey et c'est un
peu pareil là tu vois c'est si tu vas
trop fort en fait tu t'arraches la
bouche du poisson et c'est moi non mais
c'est un risque
si tu fais trop forte ça arrivera il
faut il faut avoir le bon coup de
poignet c'est très important
il coûte par avs non mais j'ai envie de
parler de pêche
j'ai le droit par les juges agité des
cuirs de bavois lâcher ça observé la
collection de parme n'est jamais à la
pêche en fait j'aimais bien c'est vrai
d'ailleurs c'est un mouvement que dans
ma culture générale ne pas pêcher une
seule fois par an au poison jamais pêché
jamais mais ça demande pas tapageur une
envie gent masculine vieri qui te vient
non
tu vois ma culotte la de messi merde
bien sûr donne moi aussi vite que
possible
21 juillet cam plage que le 28 juin je
pars dans la gamme plage que mais il dit
ça sent l'homme tu as le problème c'est
que j'ai peur que ce soit une fille en
fait ce serait quoi une fausse fille en
fait c'est un mec a une nouvelle fois
que c'est vrai que moi qu'il me rapporte
une culotte féminine en mai rappelle qu'
ils pêchent tout notre humour bien ça
chauffe eau en même temps ça devient
intéressant de cette fois-ci d'ailleurs
ils jouent pas très pop up pas trop
maniaque peut-être pas mal mais il joue
mieux en trois minutes mais c'est
souvent le cas ce qui en fait le plus du
temps qui leur donne le monde bien le
jour j'ai marqué ce a remarqué ça par
exemple c'était l'occasion pour demander
que les femmes ont joué moins bien on
réfléchit semble beaucoup et alors
qu'est ce qui se passe mais visiblement
les noirs sont mieux puisqu'il voit que
c'est le bio khemiri journal
en fait en a aussi mais le bio c'est
l'ancien champion est ok prises et 45
salaires à ses perspectives man et
winter ce2 et les deux nouveaux
instruments pour ce domaine wadder 3,2
et le temps dès lors comment ça
l'heure est venue de dieudonné et des
trois mois parce que non mais en fait
part à mme il a juste une petite baisse
de régime quand il a perdu une partie
pour connexion voici qu à l'hebdo
curieux de trois ans qu'est ce jeu deux
dingues le pion à temps je trouve g3
social et technique
j'ai trois c'est ce que j'aurais fait
pour essayer de créer un réseau de maths
et non mais oui à jean maurice technique
à temps en temps il veut tous rêvent de
mai à temps il fait pas un peu n'importe
quoi ben montre les mauvaises techniques
et 6 ans qui était qu'est-ce qui fait la
météo il ya deux rames et attend mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait quoi bon alors
voilà le fondeur joue du mec c'est pas
son truc
là il va pas les coups de l'adversaire
en fait pas du tout va faire des quatre
îles tant que le piège pas toujours
abandon mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
à quoi
bon ben ça va égaliser voilà de ne pas
jouer ses trois c'est la fatigue c'est
incroyable non finalement il finalement
quelque chose de quand même plus
tranchant je crois je passe je sais si
je suis je pense pas que c'est le mieux
je crois que les six fois au 3 mai qu'un
pas que les 2 octobre ou non mais je
suis choquée flat
enfin je suis choquée parce que c'est
quand même des mecs qui sont assez bon
normalement bis et ils font des erreurs
quand même qu'ils sont pas de leur
niveau quoi bon comme je dis en tant qu
outil du développement ada joueur
d'échecs
l'église peut être très bon bien mais il
faut jouer très sérieusement chaque
partie et maxime ont 14 16 parties par
session oui maximum le top donc
peut-être celle de faire deux matches de
wii party wii est joué pour les secours
au fond peut-être si toujours des
ouvertures préféré même regardé après
les ordinateurs les ouvertures donc mais
jamais un joueur comme ça avec la jambe
gauche oui parce que la société rial et
même pour le pire du temps pour y jouer
justement donc mais sinon c'est un outil
fantastique du progrès ou simples comme
qu'on parle pas des tomates chez toi oui
j'en ai une qui est pourri vaut mieux la
jetée parce que sinon ils ont pourri des
autres voilà paré avec les beats voilà
même maintenant bien sûr qu'on m'y
attendais site où on peut jouer c'est
surtout en utile pour jouer s'amuser
parce qu'un machin est donc peu du monde
par exemple je pense que toutes les
carrières de nos caméras montrent à quel
point le risque d'être profitable pour
ta carrière classique parce que il est
réussie de canaliser afin tout ce qu'il
a appris en blitz
si la fois par des miroirs partie de la
wii et la sueur canaliser sa pour sa
carrière classique
est-ce qu'on voit paroles c'est du
gâchis quoi c'est du talent gâchis et
csle c'est l'avenir qui pourrait
attendre au delà si quelqu'un vous y
explique pas sain est ce que tu penses
que son entraîneur paul riquet mais
c'est quand même 20 sokolov
c'est quelqu'un qui sur une boucle sur
mac on prend le problème mais après tout
donc
ok à ceux qui peuvent expliquer mais il
y en a aussi ça dépend aussi et ce que
je me vois écoute d'ailleurs tiens rien
de grave problème parce que quand on est
obligés sinon on frôle 4,5
qu'est ce qui a changé les riverains des
sites comme religieuse cette pièce je
sais pas c'est plutôt qui viennent qui
peut vous répondre je sais que je dis là
dessus c'est pas ma spécialité ça a
changé en toi de dire je suis là mais ça
a changé quoi l'arrivée des sites
internet
kappa foot pro fn avec fous j'ai trois
ce que tu veux rares et leur histoire
fond mais bien sûr les noirs sont
nettement mieux maintenant couverts mois
millions et auraient toutes été
maltraité par les bois le faux bien sûr
et cela se ressent d'ailleurs jusqu'à
présent jusqu'à présent d'ailleurs zhu
zhu une partie exemplaire mais bientôt
la merde et jusqu'à présent juste au gip
à bourran par cerf noir en bons 2007
cavalia sa colère c'est que les boues
cinq points face à changer quoi ça
change et que c'était plus facile de
jouer à jeu face à changer plein de
choses mais c'est comme l'arrivée
d'internet mais je veux dire je pensais
qu'il ya une question plus concrètes
derrière par rapport aux joueurs ça
démocratiser les échecs ça participe
comme huawei clairement mais après je
pense c'est une question plus par
rapport il va faire du site heureusement
je pensais que je pensais que c'était
une question plus comme on est restés
plus par rapport à la manière de jouer
un peu avec oui ça va apporter quelque
chose dans ce jeu là il faut faire faux
bond cette souffrance oui mais que vois
les enfants
et je sais pas peut-être jeu 5 j'aime
bien je sens que je vois pas de problème
est que ça pour l'instant les besoins
peuvent rien faire donc je sens qu'un
bourreau clos le truc
puis 17 carlos a longtemps double tour
sur scène pour frapper un moment donné
pour se voir sur ces 3 et frappé un
moment donné quand les c4 jamais je vous
prie je sens que c'est quoi les deux
colocataires
après je sais qu'avec moi j'aime bien
moi ce qui fait qu'il n'a encore mais
non avec les boys et bien organisé on
pense que les blondes réussi de
stabiliser les trucs de construction que
perdu un certain parti de son avantage
peut-être pas énorme et l'a perdu
ok maintenant bien sûr dans les trois
autres camps les trois tours si toi tu
veux jouer mais que les dessins de cinq
tours de 5 à leurs dames 3 que les trois
tours ce simple fait preuve à la fois ci
ce que j'ai pas pensé à ça se monte à
dire d'un médecin qui parle d'un besoin
que non là il ya des jachères dalida
l'intérêt de noir de changer les idées
là bas bien sûr et c'est cette ferme
sont tellement impossible ce jour
mais avant c'était plus difficile de
jouer aux échecs il n'y a pas internet
bien sûr
même un match qui va arriver ici un jour
ou l'autre
bof c'est devenu n'importe quoi pourquoi
pas dans mon art ici c'est un drame à
jouer puisqu'il y avait celle qui tombe
ouais ok quoique mais par contre l'eire
maintenant c'est l'autre qui va se
mettre un taquet ouais ben comme très
récents qui sait bien jouer comme ils
voient pas les coudées resserre donc
peut-être ça va être un challenge
sinon ça qu'il fallait pour l'adversaire
ouais je mens jamais juste c'est
tellement un gros défaut sa voix que
voler h3 est dommage qu'à terme il faut
pas avoir déjà atteint temps je leur dis
pas ce qu'on a vu non ah oui et ce qui
désole les trois juges de touche
naturelle
par contre d'autres judokas les toits je
peux l'être humain et ses choix et je
suis sûr de pouvoir c'est la partie a
été réalisée les échecs ou un pourri la
vie samedi 4 à ok il a fait ça comme ça
mais ça marche pas du coup le convoyage
droit et d'avoir été plus logique quand
vous voulez mais les caps à boire dormir
n'importe quel poste
tiens tu sais pas comment faire je vous
envoie une pause dans les régions par
correspondance par email en ligne offre
au point où tu veux quoi décret mais
c'est vrai pourquoi mais ça fait
toujours pitié de voir ça le macho
très bien née d'un coup devient juste
mondiale avait auguré et l'inde joue la
méta +51 pour jouer ça qu'on fait ça
mais inconstant la vie à plus de temps
et alors oui il a raison de jouer le jeu
que vous avez froid dames les quatre
matins j'ai mis mes lunettes de mamie
pour montrer ma sagesse devancé jaune
devant ce jour comment les appeler leur
bon les gens fous
elle est plus que l'autre
mais c'est dommage pour les uns et pour
les autres qu'ils n'ont pas passé les
courses de voiture à paris
à l'époque je pense qu il aurait perdu
pas mal de de leurs primes que c'est
ailleurs que oui oasis a pris quelque
part je pense aux etats-unis --via nos
couleurs à paris où je pense qu'ils
auraient appris pas mal de choses avec
les amis yugo avec les vocaux et compris
avec les grands maîtres gagnaire et
après pas mal de choses
oui les machines à sous les 2 machines à
sous ou quoi mais j'avais regard il
devrait progresser mais il aurait pas
que c'est par contre j'ai toujours tenté
de jouer ça marche cette coalition
souvent c'est mauvais je sais mais je
suis tenté souvent de le faire je sais
que je te cause par la russie
ouais j'ai toujours pensé que je vais
trouver ma voie russie et à je me fais
avoir
j'ai souffert mais j'ai toujours regardé
[Rires]
tout fou non j'aurais su que c'était par
ou mais j'aurai toujours par contre je
dois réussir dans ce domaine
ils m'ont fait me rappeler de la
jeunesse quoi de la juge une divinité
que je vis était au milieu des années
quatre avant les coupes je vous dise
voilà qu'on les vêtements à la con adage
l'essonne à l'encontre non mais ils 1,80
à la musique c'était pas mal quand même
oui au québec tous et que d'un point p
en france plutôt commode d'un point pris
un but en 19 86 le groupe blues en
europe c'était moto qui lie péremption
caraïbes et 6 tu t'imagines si tu
prenais du cavalier hayes peut-être
venir le pion mais les états unis
pouvaient black et pro b cette non à
cote et c'est bien son style % à 4 il
voit la chanteuse que tu écoutais
les russes ont un côté patricia kaas
menthe ou plutôt non mais t'as écouté
notre chanteuse sabrina rang prénom
comme ça où sabrina était très très
populaire
c'est à chansons préférées bof bof bof
vrai papa baba boys boys boys
j'ai bien pensé et écouter autre chose
que du clip excellent toujours le voir
attaquer le liquid regardent ils veulent
faire il veut le faire pour ces huit sur
tours s'est vite car il ya à 5
et qui sait si c'est surtout ses 8
cavaliers ses 8
bon j'ai pas vu juste non mais en fait
c'est exactement le style de
ma chandelle par an disons que il s'en
fout que leurs pions du moins il s'en
fout qu'il y au moins bien il voit son
pion qui va se démener d'accord et au
cours de ce match mais il a montré bill
fois qu'il est peu de temps après il
peut y arriver parce que l'autre on va
tout faire pour
donc mais un oui samantha fox
et sinon sandra aussi descendra donc 3
alors ça prendra sa vraie samantha fox
les tangos spécialiste des trois n'est
ce pas mais c'était même à la mode
tu sais au championnat junior d'une
série qui brille tout ce ce cahier à
félix andré off qui sont sic oignons
mais pas tous avaient les badges badge
avec eux c'est une chanteuse un we go la
davrays le grand maître israélien
il avait sabrina alexandre il avait
force ici c'est génial ça c'est des
belles histoires qu'elle est maintenant
c'était plus tard près de cali
maintenant que c'était chez nous cette
au cas où à partir de 90 je pense
arriver lundi les garçons aussi qui est
la mairie diatta qui a oui les gars ont
bien ce que les chinois qui font pas ah
oui oui on s'est laissé réutiliser les
plus peuplés occidentale de la chine
c'est fou ça tellement mal vieilli six
un élève de seconde les parents marie
laforêt je parle j'ai pas tu populaire
en russie
non je pense pas patricia kaas 13 et
même national elle a cartonné grave car
ton agréable les depuis un bon moment
avait plus russe que française autres en
fait c'est elle qui a pas pavé le chemin
pour depardieu gérard pour les intimes
est lara fabian très populaire en russie
malheureusement oui k-maro aussi camaro
à c'est assez bizarre quand c'est
l'heure il est vrai mais sinon
énormément 16 je pense que beaucoup plus
qu'en france
malheureusement non j'aime bien cette
baffe fabien demiri fans mireille
mathieu on en parle où c'est tabou mais
balle dehors de moi il va toujours
chasser les cerfs et vous mettez
toujours complices il fait simplement
parce que parmi eux y ira moi ouais je
sais pas un grand fan très grave
acropolis adieu à dio adium c'est qu'il
ya personne qui pèse 70 amateurs en
france nous sommes bien sûr il va pas
payer le numérique
l'auteur va finalement réussir de
attaquer l'euro par amo est le joueur le
plus optimiste du super il va remettre
son carrelet sur e4 et les voit même des
miens pas fait pas non plus tard de
parra mme way la position neutre et par
habitant parra mist
la ville de grasse orgas bourg je sais
pas original mais ta prière que jane
birkin et anglaise robe tutu voir
document tout le monde était fan de
kanye west wing ton problème de est âgé
que nous réduisions voilà svs gerbi ben
oui oui ça fait gagner tout de suite
nous ou quel idiot et c'est dommage
ok moi j'ai presque devenu presque à un
couperet mais après la honte on peut
gagner la c1 c'est avec les secondes sur
la pendule a vu leur classe tout peut
arriver là regarde ça a l'air de plutôt
bien choisi par un parent matelots le
matin ag souplet mme abraham
qu'est ce qu'il faut et fabrication
c'est que ça qui tourne autour commune
non mais ils le perdent beaucoup
d'appels à hockey news bas ils vont
jouer ça mais les gosses non mais c'est
fou non
mais qu'est ce que les taux sont au
rouge que nouvel essai un rat enfin il a
réussi non mais c'est vous finans c'est
fou non
les sept ans bien servir quand même de
voir chaque fois firme quitte à souffrir
non mais c'est bizarre ce qu'il a raté
les enfants battez vous pour le centre
dès les premiers cours ne cherchait pas
affirment qu'ils téléphonent à n'importe
quel prix qu'on écoute la bonne nouvelle
c'est que le match est très serré
ça c'est bien et c'est vrai que c'est un
bonheur parfait
les deux super g n du la dame en plus
c'est les meilleurs ils soient bien ils
se sont qualifiés
jusqu'ici un art ligue du blitz ils se
sont qualifiés va te prendre arriver
jusque là et ils ont plutôt massacrer
leurs adversaires enfin surtout par le
charpentier qui guérit est aussi très
étonné par certains très mauvais coups
des joueurs et ouï dire il n'est pas le
joueur du très bon niveau en glisse et
les plutôt moyenne anglaise par rapport
à son niveau de jeu grâce au g g et
super classe mais comment ces deux là
jouent ces cars gratuitement c'est vrai
bien sûr c'est marrant temps et du coup
tu peux prendre
il y avait peut-être un problème non il
vaut pas pour lui et vous pendant leurs
dix cavaliers 4 ok ok écouter après
avoir vu autant de choses tout ça
servait d'atelier appareil 3 oui là
l'année prochaine on fait commenté le
women speech s non mais je vote spéciaux
seniors 60 cloud dont 80 66 +75 plus
mais que des vieux qua non oui seigneur
religieusement mais en fait j'ai bien
aimé fitch est féminin parce que ça
donne un titre autant honnêtement le
speech junior je pense que c'est une
expérience à ne pas renouveler
oui ça va être facile non ils vont
renouveler
ils vont te plaît parce qu'il est plus
facile pour ceux qui savent pas jouer
aux échecs du sunset difficile ça se
passe aussi et avec je sais pas mais moi
je pense que généralement faudrait
supprimer le junior ou alors réduire le
nombre de joueurs
le niveau est pas assez élevé l'action
serait présent pas un bon exemple quoi
dégoûter coma profond non mais en fait
tu vois même un joueur comme guillaume
meyer j'aime pas son style mais il
s'agit quand même mieux que la meilleure
les différences internes mayer et eux
c'est un autre univers
oui c'est un univers moi quand je jouais
mayer ma dernière année pratique sur et
c'était toujours
chaud chaud chaud tag est ce que là et
tu vas à l'année dernière ce qui sont
sorti des qualifs c'est même pas
meilleur il est pas sorti ses domine
gâche qui aujourd'hui numéro 8 mondial
je veux dire par là que même dans les
qualifs tu vois des mecs d'un calibre
très élevé oui bien sûr et dominguez ça
joue bien alors 2000 grâce à dominguez
voir sur nos devos mode cloud
diongue c'est bien mais du coup tu vois
je préférerais avoir des qualifs au
speech s avec un match même tu vois des
mecs qui ont un peu oublié
je rends match thomas chef qui rendrait
eakin oui ok vous donnerai andric tu
voyais au genou tiens il ya pas mal de
joueurs intéressants quand même chez les
adultes qui jouent pas forcément et qui
donne un spectacle est quand même plus
enrichissant quoi moi en fait il se doit
vous être interdit de jouer dans glee tu
penses pas oui interdit pour progresser
non pour pas donné amour exemple les
autres d'accord ou jeu par une section
comics ok sur le site les standards
blitz monty python équipe ait un seul
instant tablette sur quoi ouais ça namco
mais jamel comedy club à marana wiiware
est comme moi tu rigoles milieu olivier
comédie française qu'on le lève aller
plus haut mouais
duda aussi qui avait été bon non marc
rich il est beaucoup plus
mais sa crasse manger ce plus haut sont
plus aussi plus la même pas du tout
avant oui même maintenant non maintenant
c'est ce qu'il fait il le met et le mc
du tgv met tous ses amis comme un gars
comme copine car oui ptête riposte pour
mon copain un gars comme toi parce que
tu sais que souscrivent tu sais que les
gars il a finalement monté une société
il engage des gens maintenant pour faire
du thé chaud quoi peut-être c'est juste
un des dogues d'être car maintenant il
faut que je l'appelle quoi est-ce que tu
as un tel morose et beach dans ta team
quoi mais tu sais que c'est un excellent
métier c'est fantastique
le sommelier du thé qu'on a mais c'est
hyper intéressant vraiment mais il doit
pas gagner beaucoup là non pas de gagner
vraiment pas beaucoup avec ce métier
mais c'est parce que il n'a pas tout mis
sur les préparations de match
non mais peut-être c'est parce que
peut-être qu'il a il a une collation une
société où pas de tirer de l'argent et
qui fait un truc quoi moreau mais c'est
un métier sujet n'y ait eu c'est que
j'aimerais bien faire c'est votre
reconversion
quand les gens me demandent qu'est-ce
que tu ferais sites arrêtés c'est un
truc que j'aimerais vraiment faire c'est
génial total gagné le spirit chose s'il
était toujours vivant
écoute est très possible c'est le
premier champion du blitz est le premier
championnat doublette a eu lieu au canad
and 19,88 tout le monde parmi les forêts
participer kasparov capovilla
boncompagni c'est elle qui a gagné dans
les finales et l'est écrasèrent va
gagner alcatel demi anatomy et c'était
donc le premier championnat de bisbilles
as you est d'ailleurs quelques mois
avant sa mort il a battu cospar au fond
de lui dans un tournoi donc bien sûr on
était capable de gagner cette occasion
et moi j'ai écrasé la gagnante quelques
années plus tard pardon géniez moi j'ai
écrasé va gagner quelques années plus
tard c'est vrai dans l'automobile mains
d'un bestiaire à se souvient d'eau salée
j'avais fait un truc marrant il avait
j'avais les pions un peu comme ça et il
avait mis le fond ces quatre révéleront
g8 avait plu prend
m saddam la angers 6 terminé je suis
pack rapidement ça et j'ai bouffé la
dame au coup d'après bon est-ce que tu
avais gagné ça avec les bons au temps au
temps mais céline working in un même
parce que parham a été déconnecté
d'internet
regarde c'est là que je te dis que le
problème d'internet qu'il est tout à
l'heure et man encore c'est un vrai
problème mentalement qu'ils étaient les
meilleurs du monde seront vos onglets
vous parlez de please dites moi s'il
vous plaît oui archi g5 c'est mille fois
plus intéressant que la mère qui le
faisait avant alors s'il faut je sens
que c'est l'un des meilleurs tours pour
le prouver il a pas fait plus tôt alors
s'y connaît
bahram il est très énervé par ces primes
de connexion mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile ça mentalement que l'e3 c'est
le coup que je déteste
bien sûr le bon point se joue avec trois
dates au groupe qu'on va lire trois
fosses à quatre ça appartient à haute au
monde pour dire que le matin dans le
sens propre mes gars a été sûrement
beaucoup plus fort que ces mecs leur
talent et tout ça non ambriz patients
questionnera peutrec histoire mais
figure toi le mec qui était mille fois
qui a visité toutes les cliniques
possible à l'union soviétique ailleurs
je parle de talus et cellmania malade
pendant un quart de siècle
quelques mois avant sa mort il bat
kasparov avec les noirs kasparov
pendant son mieux vaut donc pourquoi
est-ce que dalle pour bata cars mais si
bien sûr une rue baudin bien sûr après
tout car st il est très très très
impressionnant ce dernier anglais
j'enlève mes critiques les deux mais
parfois il est pas trop bien non plus à
vif
car mon coeur pauvre quoi même quand
même cas pour fêter excellemment please
tu vois ils ont tous les deux pensées
aujourd'hui dans la partie qui après roy
bessette c'était gagnant pour maxime
expliqué à brive et qu'il pouvait
qui pensait qu'après tous rêvent cette
fois de 8 faut des six les grandes et
mieux repenser que pratique malgré un
bon merci pour le dire c'est ce que j'ai
compris en fait en marchant au maire je
le 12 je m'en doute que les horizons
mais bien sûr donc maintenant au moins
lancer les raisons pourquoi je faisais
beaucoup de rythme furent encore plus
quand même qu' il n'y avait rien c'était
l'ami j'ai de la chance aujourd'hui
région je pense que oui avant c'est
vraiment ok je préfère au caire 14 juste
il a loupé un truc parce qu après qu les
strokes et 3m x ou y reprendre avec le
pion et sinon elle est mal le milieu
bien sûr de ne pas encaisser de kyoto
firme et le fou il a fait ok pour
l'instant parents jouent très bien sa
carrière il y avoir des grosses
séquences en fait mais je pense que tout
le monde a remarqué qu'il ya des pics
tout ce qui fonctionne dans une partie
qui joue bien je joue bien jusqu à un
moment donné puis il recommence quand
même mais les deux joueurs bien la même
partie on n'a pas vu en quoi donc une
vraie partie de gramat je pense qu'on
n'a pas vu une seule peut-être pas
encore ouais peut-être en bullet
donc encaissé le fourrage de nom j'aime
bien de l'ehpad jeu de mécanique moi
j'adore le pont du week-end je préfère
toujours de jeu et peu sur les peintures
de mécanique dommage qu'il y en a plus
beaucoup d'années doivent déjà faire
[ __ ] al 4 secondes et 6 4 oui sauf que
cette fonction puisque d'autres musées
ok parham qui va égaliser par ama tout à
fait de bien jouer cette partie ce qu'on
ne peut pas dire sur son adversaire
fouche trois bons ou moins c'est
créative où il veut garder deux prévenus
en vie quoi tic tac tic tac mois tactics
l attaque
c'est quelqu'un en chat qui va pouvoir
nous citer la france on l'aimé regarde
c'est pareil ce qui fait part à mme
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un fonctionnaire
way
car il nous dit j'ai toujours une
vieille pendule de bleed c'est vrai mais
elles sont c'est les meilleurs les
pendules ait eu connaissent chanson ta
katie t'a quitté non bob lapointe
non farage d'après nar ok donc ça va
être sur mois 7,7 très très serré le
moitié oui incroyable nos pronostics
connoté horrible avant droite a mis un
peu mieux compris que moi que le
problème du conte excitant que la
connexion mais sinon de toute manière vu
à quel point disons que fabricant même
ceux souffrant qu annoncent quoi je vois
toujours pour marche ou pas manquer ça
imaginez si au lieu de tête qu elle
s'enferme de connexion ce serait à moi
8,6 et peut-être 9,5
quand le joueur d'échecs aime toujours
les faux les faux charismatique comme
tout le monde adorait les voitures
maisons seront d'ailleurs paramètres
voilà c'est le nouveau voitures en moins
forts même pour le mondial ce conte aux
pièces 00 bouchez brigode critères
afraitane quick est grit est gratuit
bobby pas la pointe mais fish ardue
tu as i te cite maintenant boby lapointe
mais c'est marrant tu connaisse pas oui
la pointe ici tu es sûr que tu
connaissais mois il a opéré dans la zone
et il ya longtemps ses anciens amants
nous villa points de suture cette année
39 40
moi je sais c'était bianne cette
chouette nananana lorette 70 voilà
c'était encore plus
ouais j'aurais mis beaucoup et ça aussi
ça tu connais cette chanson ne quitte
cependant par baba bien riordan r us
dont xinhua
je suis et quoi ça j'aimerais que ce
soit parce que c'est le même qui a
chanté c'était bien ça te souhaite
chaleur est enfin la chanson s'appelle
chez les reds je pense que c'est le
monde mais je reste chez moi venions de
les rustres bienveillant dans les restos
xinhua oui oui mais celle des chefs
richesse des pecs voilà les hausses
cauchemar à des gens qui connaissent
quoi c'est fou c'est ce que vous sur
tout ce que moi je connais quoi annoncer
leur lcd le piège et ont cru qu'ils
connaissent pas je crois le reste on est
à quelques années qu'ils écrivent
mais à on sait pas quoi on ne sait pas
qui connaît qui connaît pas quoi
mais c'est incroyable parce qu'il
connaît mais vos piles apprendre ça va
te plaire je te connais
bon du coup
du coup fait partie très intéressante de
la part de deux jusqu'à présent présenté
au besoin d'un sursaut n'importe quoi
parce que quand on les bouge
j'aimais fièrement des bonnes cases au
quai je pensais faire çà çà çà çà mon
colis de cinq mecs à grimentz
j'ai vu la montée de gréement je
commencerai donc tu peux pas aller sur
le set tu dois te cacher sur hbo
d'ailleurs sur le case correct faut
aussi gérer le volet de 500 packs amène
à rester bien ça sympa camin il a fait
ça un tiers ne veut le voir parfois des
choses n'ont pas arrangé les choses
les choses changent jamais qu'aux
anciens souvenirs change racisme
ordinaire de l'époque c'est bien cela
barbara quoi mes amis et parents de
touristes chinois et des jeux dressage
il chantait vraiment une attaque 100 m
oui mais c'est pourri mais tu es morte à
ce concours est grève
c'est fou quoi c'est avec de telle façon
que j'ai appris le français à feu ça
fait peur aujourd'hui je serais plus
possible de faire comme ça
les précisions que non il est pas pour
plaire zoug le disons dans les prochains
mois les américains n'ont et l'américain
voilà donc je non en plus un grand fan
de la cuisine asiatique
ouais ok ok elle est réussie de tout
faire pour son adversaire par an et les
mois le temps et les traîtres est moins
sûr dans les positions ok je vois ce qui
se passait bien vraiment je suis plus
pénible que quoi que ce soit à quoi au
long de la h3
kefu qui le finisse manon tête agf a
choisi si je présente à mettre à jour
une fois et après tu attaques la tata
qui l'attaquent là surtout se battre
c'est pas trop dur même si exemple
exemple non mais ça c'est bien joué et
fougueuse d'un match 4 ok ça va me
manquer sage de lui remettre la tourache
à la guerre froide interdite rue si les
us non j'ai rien contre les yeux
peut-être à vous aviez un mois y compris
le sens de nos fais moi mal sur
l'échiquier avec le pion ouais de f3 on
peut montrer parce que c'est rare bon
plus deux anneaux plus sage ça ou je me
trompe toujours et c'est la dernière
partie il énervé par am il est énervé
non mais il va perdre mais bon la
connexion en quinze jours quand même en
vol important vous attend demain entre
les connaissances joue à craindre tout
juif hgj f3 dans deux grandes rock
il connaît pas justement il est
désespérant que miley désespérément mais
du coup je pense pas que si tu joues
russie mal contre la hollandaise moi
j'ai le même problème c'est pas mieux de
faire ce que je fais je te conseille de
sister faut que ça que tout à fait bien
si on colle et c3 que les suisses ou 2,5
aussi tout à fait bien effacer le jeu
juste donne pas la possibilité de jouer
collège cinq parisiens peu d'accord
juste ouais c'est l'alphabet deux
virtuoses qui heureusement l'autre l'a
pas fait il est un peu cyclothymique
qu'est ce qui change d'humeur souvent
comme ça oui oui bien sûr un peu comme à
vélo là par contre je pense que je
préfère les besoins quand même il a
réussi quand même d'avoir quelque chose
je suppose maintenant apparemment fatale
il a une très mauvaise habitude
un soutien il adore répéter les mêmes
chemins
oui j'ai remarqué ça ils s'en sont bien
normal
il répète ouais mais c'est la faute à
fait parce que après tout normalement tu
t'es pas trop content avec le câble et
sur dc de béziers sont normalement on
passe quoi est ce que tu cherches à vous
mettre les bras chaque fois et de toute
manière les échecs même bleed sais pas
pourquoi qui s'est quand même pour crier
des choses n'est ce pas non mais c'est
un peu carrière 4 ok découverte un
certain temps dans ma chute j'ai 6
ok c'est reparti dans les fous
larisa d'or que le bordel il arrive à
chaque fois ouais je vais toujours
essayer c'est pas vraiment un bordel ce
geste d'abandon mais j'ai l'imprimé le
crac coller de 5,5 pas beaucoup mais
j'en ressens quand ils foutent le bordel
mais ils calculent pas vraiment bon
c'est les petits gosses instantanée
qu'il faut fouetter parfois le regard s
est fait fouetter quoi mais là j'ai une
pièce de moins est il abandonné quoi du
coup il ya encore une partie en trois
minutes
tiens plus deux ça fait longtemps que
personne n'a pas eu non mais c'est lyon
qui va gagner vlad j'espère déjà depuis
un moment déjà j'espère a fait qu' aux
parents paient ses habitudes de la co op
et elle-même fait les mêmes fautes puis
acquitté il faut à chaque occasion
bof déjà à l'époque quand j'ai toujours
quelqu'un qui fuit inquiète les fous à
chaque fois c'était considéré comme le
comportement dans nos jours preview du
jeu auquel humains qui se cachent
derrière les forces les comédiens les
forteresses marle
mais qu'est ce que c'est ce comportement
est facile à apprendre à jouer aux
échecs pas l'art militaire ne vaut pas
en quoi tu penses pas plainte en plus
c'était une bonne occasion quand tu
joues en glisse comme ça de jouer plus
principal moi bien sûr
enfin dans l'union dans les coursives et
yves c'était vachement critiquable par
les plus grands spécialistes
lorsque les entraîneurs apprenait les
légendes les petites lignes c'est très
très critiqués parce que comme ça
peut-être tu vas réussir des résultats
lorsque tes gosses oui mais tu va gâcher
ta vie ta carrière juste comprenant pas
les gros slim un moment donné c'est
peut-être trop tarder à prendre des
risques hors jeu principal
principalement non mais quand même
aussi quoi toute ta vie et si toujours
que les 3 3 ou 2 3 ça va pas marcher
c'est vrai qu'ils demandent si on peut
être ta katie t'a quitté plus tôt que la
musique qui énerva si tu nous achète les
droits d'auteur cyril on peut le faire
mais il faut qu'il en soit un chèque
rapidement bah oui la chanson de pêche
si nous en voirie nous avons un gros
chèque
donc malgré tout je pense que le chemin
afin de voler les véhicules rapporte
soudain tombé dans vos propos aulas qui
est longue
désolé pas résisté pendant deux heures
et demie voilà ouais ok ils voient que
c'est notre vie annoncée bram que je ne
dis pas cela il va gagner bien sûr parce
que
ouais f5 web ou la commande est réussie
de provoquer sans que je sais pas
comment il a fait rigoler un peu
heureusement cru qu'on pouvait rigal du
pouce de chase co attends attends temps
ils menacent dames 3 à 8 peut-être et
tout reprendre cette année il peut
peut-être faire fois qu'ils s'assurent
une matheuse peut-être ça sort pas les
parties où il faut aussi se restaurer la
russie s'est qualifiée tour de oui c'est
facile
badarou et l'a pas vu l'armée ok mais
c'est quand même trop mais moi je les ai
vus on n'avait pas leur dit quoi j'ai
juste vu tempo comme ça entre deux
blagues
non mais il s'est tout match quand même
la ddt et eux ils voient les pièces en
bois
c'est un peu too much non on a eu un bon
il va quand même gagné
donc plus ans pour les mairies cannes à
voir le bout des doigts et a chuté quoi
c'était beau quand tu te vantes est de
dire l'américain américain américain
évidemment le chinois n'ont pu sauver
plusieurs l'asiatique t'aurais pas
chuter avec ce bon paquet pour ne pas
être jamais plus ajouté je veux dire
environ ricard pas oublié oui le
quadrille pronostics pour le bullet
param param param param param param
param param tu nous fais ir et d'être
irréguliers trucks où j'ai peur que dans
3 des mots pas très catholique pour à la
place de l'iranien maintenant je lance
une pub si jamais quoi et la pause à
tout ce n'est pas prendre de risque
[Musique]
allez vlad c'est reparti on est parti
les foufous dernier ne s'est pas au
qatar c'est très intéressant après je
sens sa mono joue très intéressant mais
j'aurais tenté e 4 dès le deuxième coup
on voit même le premier procès après je
sens que troisième que qu'après en tout
cas c'est très intéressant donc favoris
et l'adq envolée ceux-ci se parler de
cette collision
sassus la normalité ok je sais pour qui
déjà bon je suis pour part pour exemple
parce que entre deux tétées pour pas
maman émeutes âge aussi pour le joueur
américain
exact le riz comme le carry yank un
gringo donc sauf que j'aime parce qu'il
fait tabac ce qui fait je n'aurais pas
fait cavalier seul élève comme il faut
trois hommes se sent pas bon pour les
boulettes mais je pense sont plus fort
que toi en ville est à oui on voulait
tout le monde mais sur un vrai échiquier
ses patates aurait été plus fort tu vas
pas y arriver là si tu veux dire cette
blague n'a pas donc pas perdu c'est fini
on fait ça donc ça répète non ça joue
d'ailleurs donc si encore plus de 20
points de plus mais parra ma déprime de
connexion c'est vraiment important de le
rappeler parce que c'est ça peut être
décisif dans ce match au final mais bon
avoir une bonne connexion ça fait partie
du jeu là non et oui je pense que
maintenant d'où les prix ont pu avoir
un endroit où vous dit peut-être comment
connecter correctement je pense que
c'est pas ça existe partout quoi annonce
péquiste armes avec mon staff on a
trouvé ta maman de moi c'était pas
évident - dans son sillage arkema s'est
battu avec les clés 4g
bien sûr bon le seul problème de noir
est malheureusement très grave c'est le
col et je sais ce serait plutôt une
position correcte mais cavaliers je sais
tu sais a dit quoi il est coupé du jeu
ouais maintenant il faut faire gaffe de
ne pas perdre quelque chose tout de
suite fait 8
oui moi j'aurais fait des trois voies si
ce chèque
je pense que c'était les meilleurs cyclo
dans notre dame de droit la droite de
taille au vert dès 6 ans et 4 ans qui
disent bon on a tous les noms n'ont pas
pu hélas tout nouveau et la même radio
le collège de cet outil
mais ce n'est pas évident mais il arrive
mais l'autre a remis par me défendre et
je contredis compagne et voulait être
des boules être une façon je joue bien
en fait nous mêmes allées noires peuvent
facilement devenir meilleur voici votre
mec qu'a pas qu'on va laisser c'est
comme les 10 aux lancers francs se
blinder son roi parce que c'est les
bullet tu sais et après avoir beaucoup
progressé en blitz
j'arrive plus du tout ajout ambühl est
en fait c'est juste que si tu joues bien
ambitieux va bien que l'ambulance parce
que c'est différent comme jeu oui tout à
fait c'est juste un autre jeu maintenant
elle veut faire que les jeunes à 3,5 5,9
ça marchait pas très léger 3 pour les
joueurs pas cru ses cadres ce cas tu as
bossé comme le 6
ces choses là dans les gosses à l'ecosse
en écosse en écosse et twh de cause à
tant il a il a filé le pion laddh qui
est 17 sa fille les pions c'est vraiment
pas dire à mme toumi une baronne domine
donc pas rama quand même se débrouillent
mieux là lorsque ça devient n'importe
quoi politiste ils se débrouillent mieux
voir de jeunes ouzbeks non mais j'adore
la crise car ils y arrivent à gagner non
pour rien n'est fait qu'est ce que c'est
bg avec le beau gosse un beau gosse ces
femmes d'ailleurs je ne veux jeunes au
t1
j'aime libye cimer comme bon mais ce qui
va gagner ou pas non un lexique nick
paraît non saturés fait part hier du cas
la partie qui dut anglade
sa mère est déjà l'une des meilleures
c'est ce qu'il a dit que c'est l'un des
meilleurs depuis le début du mois d'août
mais qu'est ce que je sais les bullet
voient arriver ils vont jouer beaucoup
mieux j'étais prévenue mais attend
attends est-ce que c'est pas les plantes
qui peuvent bien sûr mbaye fofonov ok
c'est facile mais ok c'est nul ça même
ok
non mais ok c'est pas mal ce qui fait ok
ok regard rivé au regard il a joué avec
0,1 à ce sens laisse à aa1 où il tient
au quai dommage pour lui il a laissé
trop de temps aux mecs et pour gagner
fallait qu'ils fassent le truc salle de
facteurs va du pays quatre équipes
françaises
il aurait pu le faire pour l'autre avait
une seconde en fait tu vois il aurait pu
jouer psychologie puisqu'il n'avait pas
le temps de faire d'arbres et à dire
pour une fois elle même pas mises sont
fous sur bodoï c'est dommage qu'il n'ait
pas fait sa croix le 3é faute quoi mais
si c'est dommage qu'à 3
non se trouve pas ça dommage si si tu
voi s'y colle aux quatre armées valls un
autre jeu là t'es complètement largué je
pense c'est juste pas ton jeu blanc moi
j'appartiens pas à ce monde le non pas
du tout on sent ces violents car fo ap
damas quatre îles la peau mais c'est
typique bullet n'empêche possible que
vos papiers
non mais il est fort c'est un bull et
east il est fort en bullet fly
mais c'est plutôt monde en est ce que tu
te sens vieux quand tu regardes ça je me
sens inspirée mais terry murray
parce que si tu avais tu es jeune tu
aurais joué à s'assurer
pas si haut poissy déjà par exemple pour
les roses que j'étais gosse j'étais le
seul qui détestait crise 11 8 à 4 ou
crazy rage creuser nos enfants de condat
oui de gare ou bacau je détestais tout
le monde a duré moins tout le monde va
zy va bien vous êtes bons trucs tu
menace que les besoins qu'avaient je
peux plus marquée des cinq là à gagner
l'europe et le canada mérite américano
pas coller de saada mais trois bosses
dames 500 de buy a parfois fait cavaler
prend you il a raté le fou aussi et sur
quatre cavalières 3 où ils viennent
filer deux pièces là c'est chaud est ce
qu'il ya des chances qu'il va pas gagner
ça avec non non je pense que tu gagnes
tu es noir
ça va être un gros coup au moral de
parole moi je gagne avec le nord est ce
que oui ok mais celui-là tchad vision
que joue d'habitude dans ces positions
de la voix je sais à 6 tout à fait bien
je repère que vos joueurs
chartrand qui ont des meilleurs instants
bullet beaucoup l'argent que ce sont de
graves
ouais comme quoi tu as le problème
c'était la cadence c'était trop lent
pour avant au f5
là ils sont parfaits non ils voient tout
un poème voit toujours les favoris les
faiblesses de l'adversaire et jamais
rien je me laisse froid je crois mais
sarr défaut rédhibitoire de fautes
contre les verrues deux minutes n'ont
maintenant plus un génie quoi paris
regarde oui incroyable les instincts
excellent ont lieu tout est bien
maintenant il faut finir bern le fou sur
la gamme la grande terre gardoise voyez
réfléchi essaye de faire ou ceux ci
regarde il fait quoi bon pourquoi pas
pas sûr qu'ils gagnent encore tout
racheter pour 2 5 fois aussi célèbre feu
assez bien joué c'est chacun parisien
force 3 exemplaires et tapas 10 au 14
août a pas besoin de deux minutes
incroyable non
et lady flo maryland flou mais le flou à
la ntm non la sss apparemment sueur non
ce type n'est pas un athlète n'apparaît
que dans cette cadence nous faisions que
c'est une révélation du tournoi
en fait c'est un génie quoi en quelque
sorte
en fait loin du temps où il à l air d un
stade recife enfin le plus laid de temps
il veut se réformer la pleutre regarde
il va dieval mater salle d'audience
l'autre parce que jouent les studios
mais il arrive que la ligue 1 c'est un
fou et paroisse pas le shaq va me
regarde quel génie ceux qui ont tout
d'un coup quand elle son niveau à
écouter une voix joue pas contre eux
mêmes avec l'ajout du temps non il est
bien bas 4 ème à la 4 éme ne mettra des
mois à 6 peut-être dans ce cadre à
quatre prochains matchs sur l'échiquier
l'atout gagnant 4 6 6 4 et 6 4 ou 5 b
après coller à sa 7e coller des six
niveaux car lycées cette chance là des
corps à corps et si c'est un peu plus
fort parce que ma part de plusieurs
collègues
mais de toute façon c'est derrière ses
machines ont joué cavalier bougeait peu
4 et ça recommence
ils vont revenir ils reviennent toujours
marie vraiment bon tiens regarde il voit
les phobies lice chez la banque d'avoir
lé faut blesser les autres heureux bref
pourquoi pas moi qui choisis coup le
scot il revient à quoi ok tourbe et un
roi c'est un petit nom et si tout bois
est bon car il a plus de connexions part
à mme roy 3 3 3 bien sûr
voici 3 n'est pas une fois non plus à
damas cinq faux précise ce qui est vrai
les anciens on approuve
j'espère surtout qu'on prend à 10 pour
le public tout mouvement c'est bien sa
victoire ok admettons n'ai plus joué de
la cour des êtres tout en bullet
ambulants marrant et si jamais m intrus
clavicule 6-16 à messi très mauvais et
j'ai jamais même kasparov ou autre chose
mais il
mais j'étais surprise j'avais ma carte
était un peu court il avait un truc trop
quoi mais du coup tu as vu même là il
joue bien avec les noirs
quelle classe un bouge personne à
comprendre aux uns c'était pas si
terrible que ça non ah si regarde moi
j'aurais fait roi g8 à parce que je
casse
mais le transit sur le canal il reçoit
beaucoup de soin buccal
ok je rage évident que 17
qui est fier de ta blague avec manager à
beaucourt oui c'est surtout sa blague
comme dans leur salon il y avait un peu
de peter non mais j'en ai pas malice
faire un peu écrasée dans les clés
noires est par contre beaucoup chacun
parce que ces entrepreneurs
parce que la voie qu au québec que tu es
en jeu et le match s'est joué aux échecs
peu importe disons non je sais pas trop
critique en cailloux mec fait des
erreurs des fautes sauf s'ils sont des
fautes à grands traits la main écrit
noir il sait il s'en est bien sorti
quand même parce qu'ils étaient mal là
d'un coup ils commencent de voir des
choses
elle est rapide et décrire les instants
sont bons ça joue correctement les gens
comprennent les positions mais quelle
métamorphose qu en fait c'est juste
qu'ils font trop de bullet et pas assez
blitz et du coup ils savent pas quoi
faire avec le pain c'est qu'on
désespérait housewives savent pas quoi
faire avec le temps quoi faire
les cuisines fait tout est clean quoi
faire dé connaître avant 2019
que faire pour les femmes avec le temps
si la cuisine faite et la maison est
propre ni quoi faire là dessus mais
marlène schiappa en sueur quoi me
regarde c'est dans monstres que je vois
ça avancerait comprend tout ce taux bas
mais c'est vraiment un monstre à mons
s'est réveillée lablad monstrueux mais
cette affaire +4 il reste combien de
temps bas même quand tu regardes et leur
foyer de s'endormir mille fois pendant
les quatre ans précédents mais hélas il
émaille livres a les yeux brillent un
verre c'est peut-être ça fait plaisir
vraiment bonjour américain très fort les
world de la nation fort écoute ça fait
plus 4 par aman sueur a pas la
destruction
ouais mais un v6 pour la première fois
il joue le rôle le plus fort h4d 6 h 6
et le coup passa bien trop opportuniste
la seule chance de par am c'est tout
gagné à vlad une nulle et c'est fini
l'importance des mets pour tout donner
cd qui s'était obispo ou florent pagny
je m'appelle le stade où la vente
non c'était dit florent pagny je pense
ou de lobbies pop les pistes pause
c'était pas au nom de la rose
si je pense non si c'était franc de la
rose web - tant qu cois au coeur ou les
deux pourraient peu moi le tenant leur
ai dit ce normand il agit cas mais il a
pensé corps donc ils disent et plus et
plus par as et paracétamol
paracétamol a prestement et il est parti
a ajouté rice a d'ailleurs non en train
de faire toujours de nos camerino
conneries ma fête du printemps
moi je suis ce que le sacrifice et
lorient n'a pas eu ça n'a juste pas le
nom de la rose d'umberto eco oui je le
sais je parlais de chansons c'est encore
un bouquin comme quoi mystique à nombre
de livres etc sont d'ailleurs les séries
télévisées cette année la sortie cette
année fantastique avec john turturro
principal mais ça parle de quoi du coup
seulement 14e ou 6 et que je pense un
monastère tout au nord de l'italie de
l'italie il assure t elle enfin noir ça
s'est fait tuer sous les circonstances
mystique deuxième jour deuxième et sait
que le début les mois comment se faire
tuer à comprendre pas par qui comprend
pas pourquoi est ce que je peux attendre
c'est quoi ça est-ce que ça me casse les
yeux je comprends pas qu'ils voient
rouge à ok ok c'est juste fou quoi mais
ça à permettre à paraître un peu revenir
au score
donc plus trois alors on les regarde
avec 20 minutes pour finir non par hamid
et il essaye de faire du great choque
pas retarder le plus possible pour
gagner le match
federici
ça montre une belle culture des cinq ça
c'est bien pour les blancs au moins 15 5
2 5
c'est la folie quoi
ben là c'est fou non
c'est quoi bof février ou quoi bayer son
compatriote près tout donc le joueur
américain récrie noirlac ya une occasion
en or valade de lampard gré ok ok il va
gagner
je suppose que malgré tout les millau
même beaucoup il va gagner c'est la d6
coller de celle prônée six tours joués
et sarah scellé le sort du match
j'ai quand il faut toujours un j'ai
confiance qui empêchera pas de toupet
savoureusement ailleurs à trois du
couple annoncera en direct demain
affectant sa part les à quoi cet habit
pour sauf distraction regarde oui c'est
quoi cette pitié pour l'autodestruction
oh les gars y'a pas d'âme à 5
tout peut achever quatre oies et là
c'est mal parce que dans ces six dans ce
6e ne peut être plus là mesdames 5 ces
fouilles dans ce sac madame 6,6 été
mille fois plus intéressant comme ce que
marc maintenance et l'aude
avant cela ce chocquois bhl je peux pas
prendre cette eau qui l'avait fait
tourner la roue peut tourner
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont lieu demain si
je devais jouer qu'émetteur juste ça
paraît très intéressant
rv 7j 7 oui mais les noirs attaque aussi
j'ai l'accès le coffret il lui manque un
temps et en plus il ajouté le mot dit
et maintenant ils jouent pour fnatic ah
mais non il ya dames 1 quel sens c'est
la dernière blague femmes c'est la
dernière en jeu puisque la dame 1 je
pense que ça maintenant cheikh fateh
dames et paris vii et avaient fait la
même
bah c'est fini le joueur américain se
qualifie pour la finale
yes yes me reste quatre parties à jouer
trois quatre partis même pas quatre
points d'écart belle victoire il a
détruit en bullet mais il était plus
fort un finalement exemple alors qu'au
début c'était par am qui dansaient de
partout mais il a arrêté de danser
l'orgueil est tout rouge maintenant mais
mr toma et toi et pereira bien qu est-ce
que les motifs
mais ce tome est un gars exigeons qu'il
est très tranquille donc vision qu'est
ce que tu penses par une chance contre
fil rouge à en finale hawken juste recul
d'autres de la boucherie llc chollat des
donc demain à 14 heures on suivra ce qui
nous intéresse plus on va se parler
franchement on est quand même plus
intéressés par la demi finale du grand
prix par ce match oui mais ce n'est ce
pas oui comment c'est un grand jour gris
chaud que les bras eh bien ils vous
révèlent doit échoir sûrement essayer
la nappe n'est pas tant que je sais pas
mais moi je m'attends rien alors il est
très fort en contre attaque
la plage des sticks les classes approche
le classe de philosophie
l'un des philosophes newey
donc gérard depardieu sera là bien sûr
voilà bien viard depardieu je pense
qu'il est pour qui parce que lui aussi
il est comme ça quoi les deux passeports
gérard et l'adorent poutine
tu sais malgré tout que ne jamais se
prononcer sur le sujet de poutine dont
est plutôt pas bon signe pour meeting
une fois le mec ce donc une fois le mec
se prononcent pas
tu sais ce qu'ils pensent non donc
gérard va être pour son ex-compatriote
heures donc gérard sera pour maxime
c'est un coup dur pour toi non non non
ces derniers temps c'est un mauvais
souvenir temps là je ne trouve pas bien
je viens de regarder les séries qui
visait marc s'est pas excusé moi c'est
mais cela est rare c'est urgent et
rafale si oui bien sûr oui mais de
m'avoir tambwe de 2008 40 jusque 2007 70
c'est dommage et qui sait plus le même
qu'à tous les mêmes tous les mêmes tous
les mêmes y en a marre
citations je pourrais me dire qui je
travaille je pense pas qu'il ya sur ce
que je pense pas d'ailleurs très
populaire monsieur oui on avait oublié
mais les belges très franches aux 16
mètres est très populaire
l'eau jacques brel moderne en quelque
sorte en grâce au formidable du jeu que
tu aimais bien brassens ou difficile à
construire à main le stylet moyens sont
français et trop sophistiqués dont la
moitié de match qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai acheté
le livre mais à chaque fois il m'a fallu
traduire c'était fatigant mais sinon
j'aime bien le style et le flou ou mais
c'est vrai que ben qu'avec ce bourg j'ai
adoré le style surtout son style de vie
oui mais là deux tiers de droit vont
penser à 14 mois et renault j'ai
toujours 1 ce 2 juin toujours l'hexagone
c'est que c'est interdit à la radio oui
je pensais que vous avez dit c'est
interdit non ça joue ça je pense que
j'ai entendu au moins je pensais que
c'est interdit mais la dernière de
propos le dernier de leur non je parle
beaucoup par exemple il a trahi ses
aigus mais il le dit et je pense au
moins honnêtes
ouais c'est vrai d'autres ne le sont pas
et armand vois tu connais non non parce
que le match est fini
en fait c'est un jeu pour du beurre
latuquois l'ouverture des jeux du cac a
testé quatre cadres le petit hangar à
titicaca car l'orage de brassens ok je
veux faire tout seul j'espère que la
partie va durer encore 45 secondes pour
pas avoir encore une autre aux fruits
vous jours en fait je suis toujours
énervé quand les matchs continuent quand
c'est déjà fini
moi j'aime pas ça en fait j'ai pas toi
mais quand le match est déjà gagné un
jour oui bien sûr ça doit être ce parti
ce parti le sportif
ouais silvio avoir l'accès à la télé un
beau jour un beau jour comme sur moi je
serai plus sur la planète heures quand
même il faut qu'un moteur sportif va
crier le format sportif et tout ça c'est
bien trop à la nation quoi voit pas du
tout impressionnée par qui par la partie
impression
bon je l'aimé je sais pas qu'est ce que
c'est que ça ok c'est gagnant bien sûr
pour le bon pour les noix à ce qui se
met à boulder mois normalement se
gagnera peut-être plus facilement mais
ça doit aller je pense rage et 4 dames
f53 jeune andré sirois j4 ça va et vient
du matériel
une tour kovalev 4 x 4 d'un mode deux
rangées 3,12 recadre atteindre 4,5 c pas
l'histoire loving ouais ça va là non ce
que tu dis quoi
ben c 4 c'était bien joué mais ça ne
suffit pas non ça va pour les noirs
émotif et du coup c'est une nouvelle
victoire pour jefferies qui gagnait 4
points d'écart blad donc ça fait quoi +4
jusqu'à très bon un peu dire mérité en
bullet hell est bien bas il a mérité il
a mérité le match vlad
donc voila c'était un petit intermède
avec ce petit stream tranquille mais bon
c'est pas donné à fond mon plus jeune
étant fatigué pour le commenter soyons
honnêtes parce que c'est quand même
demain mais les releveurs biotope
c'était assez dur d'ailleurs de
commenter parce que les tournants on
était complètement imprévisible complet
par özil
d'ailleurs c'est elle et moi je loue
plus émotif que j'aimerais goodman et
l'ail oui de toute ma vie j'ai jamais vu
un match aussi émotionnel jamais nous
sommes donc peut-être ça le nombre et
les méthodes la nouvelle bêta de la
méthode méthode est sûre cela donc c'est
la méthode tu pense oui
sur cela a demandé à de manille pour le
choc à 14 heures richard m vergel ils
sont de l'offre et du coup j'en vois un
raid sur la chaîne principale
bonsoir à tous
le renne laddh c'est encore fini
tiens-toi onze type s'il vous plaît pour
les interviews le raid est lancé preuve
du no fake je lance le raid
le raid est lancé jarret